TWELFTH -- WE WILL SINCE WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISHED
YET WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
AND I DID WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT
TODAY WE WILL BE -- LIMITING
TESTIMONY TO THOSE IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO FIVE MINUTES.
FOR A SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
THEN WE WILL HAVE THE ADD ONS
AFTER THAT. TO TO THAT SO WE
WILL BEGIN.
WITH WE DO HAVE A FOUR ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR LET ME JUST --
REVIEW THAT ITEM SIXTEEN AB SIX
FORTY FOUR SEVENTEEN A. B. SIX
SEVENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
TWO WHICH IS ITEM EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IS A C. R.. FIFTY OF
THOSE ARE ON THE CONSENT WE WILL
TAKE THOSE UP AS AFTER WE
ESTABLISH REPORT AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
IT'S AWESOME WELCOME THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AB ONE SEVENTY AS WAS
INSPIRED BY THE STORY OF SANDRA
PESKY GATHER.
AT A HOTEL WORKER WHO BRAVELY
CAME FOR TO TELL HER STORY ABOUT
BEING SEXUALLY HARASSED ON THE
JOB.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROTECT OUR
VULNERABLE LOW WAGE WORKERS WERE
OFTEN WOMEN AND WOMEN OF OLOR
IMMIGRANTS AND WHO ARE MOST IN
NEED OF PROTECTION FROM SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
THE TREND WE'VE SEEN ESPECIALLY
IN JANITORIAL AND HOTEL
HOUSEKEEPING SERVICES HAS BEEN A
TOWARD HAS BEEN A TREND TOWARD
OUTSOURCING WORK TO STAFFING
AGENCIES.
THESE WORKERS MAY GO TO WORK
EACH DAY AT THE SAME LOCATION
WEARING THE UNIFORM OF THE
OFFICE OR HOTEL THAT THEY ARE
CLEANING AND REPORTING TO
MANAGERS ON SITE.
HOWEVER THESE CONTRACTING
COMPANIES AND HOTELS ARE NOT
HELD RESPONSIBLE ONE SEXUAL
WRAPPED.
HARASSMENT HAPPENS ON THEIR
WATCH TO THEIR WORKERS WHAT HAS
RESULTED FROM THIS LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OUR HORSE.
USES IN THE WORKPLACE
PERPETRATED PERPETRATED BY THE
SAME ACTORS OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITH NO RECOURSE FOR THE WORKER.
AB ONE SEVENTY WOULD ENSURE THAT
THE CONTRACTED WORKERS CAN SEEK
RECOURSE FROM BOTH THEIR DIRECT
EMPLOYER THEIR CONTRACTING
EMPLOYER IF THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED ANY FORM OF
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
THIS BILL IS TO REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS ONCE THEY HAVE LEARNED
OF THE HARASSMENT TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE AND APPROPRIATE
CORRECTIVE ACTION TO STOP THE
HARASSMENT PREVENT FURTHER HARM.
BY REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO SHARE
CIVIL LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
CIVIL LIABILITY WORKERS WILL BE
MORE EMPOWERED TO HOLD THEIR
WORKPLACES ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVE
THEIR COMPLAINTS TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
I HAVE WITH ME.
I THANK YOU GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS I HAVE TO SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT 'M CO PRESIDENT
OF UNITE HERE LOCAL LEVIN.
WE REPRESENT THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
HOTEL.
RESTAURANT AND FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS IN LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTIES AND ALSO IN
ARIZONA.
I'M ALSO CHAIR OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF ORANGE COUNTY WELL
FORMALLY HOUSE ENDORSED AB.
ONE SEVENTY UNITE HERE LOCAL
LEVIN IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
SPONSORED OFFERS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY
SANDERS LAW.
I SPEAK TO YOU AS A FORMER HOTEL
WORKER AND SOMEONE WHO'S HEARD
TOO MANY STEPS.
FROM WORKERS IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
TAKE THE CASE OF SANDRA IS
GATHER A FORMER DISHWASHER AT
THE RITZ SEAT TERROR NAY A
RESORT IN RANCHO PALOS VERDES
CALIFORNIA.
LIKE MANY DISHWASHERS IN OUT THE
TERROR INDIA SANDRA WAS EMPLOYED
THROUGH A TEMPORARY AGENCY
SHORTLY AFTER SHE BEGAN WORKING
SANDRA'S MALE SUPERVISOR
ALLEGEDLY BEGAN TO SEXUALLY
HARASSED HER.
SHE ALLEGE THAT WHEN SHE
REBUFFED HIS SEXUAL ADVANCES THE
SUPERVISOR RETALIATED AGAINST
HER.
CHANGING HER SCHEDULE AND
CUTTING HER HOURS AFTER SHE CAME
FORWARD TO REPORT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SHE WAS FIRED.
EVEN THOUGH SANDRA WORK EACH DAY
AT THE TERROR NAY AYE WASHING
THE RESORTS DISHES ALONG SIDE
RESORT.
PEOPLE WORKING FOR AND
MANAGEMENT WORKING FOR THE
TERROR AND ASK THEY DENIED
RESPONSIBILITY IN PART BE
BECAUSE SHE AND THE SUPERVISOR
WHAT LOGICALLY HARASSED HER OR
EMPLOYED THROUGH THE AGENCY.
I MAGAZINE RECOGNIZE SANDRA'S
COURAGE IN SPEAKING OUT BY
INCLUDING HER AMONGST THE
SILENCE BREAKER WHO NAMED WHO
WERE NAME TIME PERSON OF THE
YEAR AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN SHE
WAS ABLE TO WHEN A SETTLEMENT
WITH THE STAFFING.
IN APRIL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN YET
THE TERROR NAY A CONTINUE TO
DENIED RESPONSIBILITY.
ON MAY TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE LA
TIMES QUOTED TERNI AS PRESIDENT
TERRY HACK BY SAYING THAT HER
ALLEGATION HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE TYRANNY.
AB ONE SEVENTY WILL UT AN END
TO THE ARGUMENT THAT COMPANIES
LIKE TO TEAR ENACT.
USED TO DENY RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
SUB CONTRACT EMPLOYEES ARE
ALLEGEDLY HARASSED AT WORK.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW COMPANIES
MUST ALREADY SURE THE CIVIL
LIABILITY WHEN THEY'RE LABOR
TRACTORS FAIL TO PAY WORKERS.
AND YOU KNOW TAKE CARE AND
PROVIDE WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE.
AB ONE SEVENTY WILL EXTEND THE
SAME SOUND PRINCIPLES TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AB ONE SEVENTY WILL ONLY APPLY
TO BUSINESSES THAT HAVE MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES AND
HIRE MORE.
THAN FIVE SUBCONTRACTED WORKERS
TO PERFORM LABOR WITHIN THEIR
USUAL COURSE OF BUSINESS.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT HIRING A COUPLE
OF PLUMBERS OR ELECTRICIANS TO
FIX UP WHAT PROBLEM IN A SMALL
BUSINESS.
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE A
LARGE COMPANIES CANNOT USER
LABOR CONTRACT TO SKIRT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROVIDING A
WORK ENVIRONMENT FREE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
I URGE YOU TO STAND WITH WORKERS
LIKE SANDRA AND SUPPORT AB.
ONE SEVENTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT -- MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO AND THANK
YOU.
YES HARM BY THE CALIFORNIA PLAN
MILLERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JOHN FAMILY CALIFORNIA COALITION
AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER FINLEY.
RENEE BAYARDO AS HELL YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRISSY THEM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING SHANNON SMITH CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA AS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS PORT.
THANK YOU.
WEBER A BATH OF CALIFORNIA ASKS
ME IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO -- ONE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS A REMINDER. FIVE MINUTES
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS UP AND
HAVING COME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL.
WE WOMEN ARE CONCERNED WITH
AUTOMATIC IMPOSITION OF JOINT
LIABILITY IN ALL SITUATIONS
INVOLVING THESE TYPE OF CLAIMS.
I THINK WE GET ALL THE VISION
CASES WHERE IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE
TO HAVE JOINT SHARED LIABILITY
DEPENDING ON THE SEARCH.
THE CASE WHERE THERE'S REQUISITE
DIRECTION AND CONTROL.
BY THE CLIENT EMPLOYER BUT WE
CAN ALSO ENVISIONED CASES WHERE.
THE KIND OF PLAYER HAS NO
DIRECTION OR CONTROL OR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE SITUATION AND
IN OUR OPINION THIS BILL WOULD
IMPOSE JOINT LIABILITY
AUTOMATICALLY IN THAT SITUATION --
SO FOR THAT REASON WERE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE JOINT LIABILITY.
WE ALSO THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE JOINT
LIABILITY THAT WAS ENACTED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND LABOR CODE
SECTION TWENTY TEN POINT.
THREE WHICH EXTENDS JOINT
LIABILITY FOR WAGES AND FAILURE
PROVIDE WORKERS COMPENSATION AND
WE CAN THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS FOR ANY TYPE OF
HARASSMENT CLAIM.
OFFER WAGES AND WORKERS COMP
DESERT.
RELATIVELY OBJECTIVELY
VERIFIABLE.
MATTERS TO CHECK THAT YOU CAN
REVIEW PAYROLL RECORDS OF A
CONTRACTOR YOU CAN YOU HEAR
AUDIT.
YOU CAN CHECK WORKERS
COMPENSATION COVERED WITH A
PHONE CALL OR CHECKING ON A WEB.
AND THE MANTRA OF AB AT NINETY
pDO A GOOD JOB VETTING YOUR
CONTRACTORS.
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE THE SAME.
ABILITY TO DO SO NECESSARILY
EXIST WITH.
UNLESS THERE'S SOME PUBLIC
RECORD OF PREVIOUS CLAIMS.
THERE'S NOT THAT THE SAME
METHODOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO
PROPERLY THAT.
CONTRACTORS FOR THESE TYPE OF
CLAIM SO WE THINK IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE TO EXTEND.
LIABILITY WE THINK THE CURRENT
APPROACH WAS THAT CASE BY CASE
DETERMINATION WHERE THE KING.
CASE I LOOKS AT THE FACTS
INTERMENTS THE LEVEL OF CONTROL
THAT WAS INVOLVED STRIKES THE
PROPER BALANCE.
AND SO WE THINK IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE TO AUTOMATICALLY
IMPOSED A LOT JOINT LIABILITY N.
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
CAN STONE ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THE
CONTRACTING EMPLOYER DOESN'T
HAVE SUPERVISORY AUTHORITY OVER
THE EMPLOYEES OF THE CONTRACTOR.
NOR DO THEY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR TRAINING THOSE PEOPLE AND ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION SO
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO IMPOSE
LIABILITY ON THEM FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTIVELY
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATIE HAVE SOME OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION PROPOSED THANK YOU.
HEY SEAN THOSE NATIONAL
FEDERATION IN A BEEN A BUSINESS
OR BRING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ALSO POSE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THE FORGES ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY.
THE MORNING MATTHEW ON WESTERN
GROWERS ALSO POST THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
READ IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
THE NON -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE I MEAN I THINK THIS
EVENT IN THE AMENDMENTS THERE
WERE SOME AMERICA.
TECHNICAL WORK ARE YOU WILLING
TO ACCEPT ACTUALLY I WENT I WANT
TO THANK -- IN FACT YOUR STAFF
FOR POINTING OUT WHAT WHEN WE
TRANSFERRED OVER -- DEFINITIONS
OF THEY WERE INCOMPLETE THANK
YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL TAKE THOSE
MOMENTS IS VERY MUCH.
IN THE NO I APPRECIATED I THINK
THIS IS A WE NEED TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO ENCOURAGE EMPLOYEES.
BUT THERE BE THE DIRECT HIRE
CONTRACT AND TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
LEGISLATION FORWARD I TO CLOSE I
JUST RESPECT LAST WHEN I VOTE
WHEN I GUESS YOU OVER TIME YET
WE WILL HOLD.
WELL THAT BILL UNTIL WE DO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH TO MOVE NOW TO ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN
THAT WORKS YEAH.
I AM BRINGING FIVE FORTY SEVEN
BACK MISTER CHAIR ON A PASS THIS
HOUSE LAST YEAR -- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DID NOT THINK
IT WAS READY TO BE SIGNED I I
THINK WE'RE IN A BETTER POSITION
THIS YEAR -- JANITORIAL WORKERS
ARE AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
WORKERS IN OUR SOCIETY AS WE'VE
HEARD BEFORE -- IT'S
INCREASINGLY A FEMALE WORKFORCE
OFTEN IMMIGRANTS WHO WORK ALONE
AND IT MIGHT IN THE ISOLATION
FROM CO WORKERS AND PUBLIC
REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SOMEONE INTERVENING.
OR SERVING AS A WITNESS TO THE
RAMPANT OCCURRENCES O SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
THAT HAPPEN IN THE WORKPLACE AND
I SAY SEXUAL VIOLENCE WITHOUT --
WITH MEANING AB WHEN WE
ORIGINALLY BROUGHT OUR OUR
JANITORIAL SEXUAL HARASSMENT
RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT WELL I'M
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD
ASSUMED ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SEEM TO BE YOU KNOW.
SOMETIMES BAD JOKES OR THINGS
THAT WERE SAID -- MORE TALK
ABOUT JANITORS WE WE SEE MORE
AND MORE -- INSTANCES OF TRUE
SEXUAL ASSAULT -- RAPE AND SO
THIS ISN'T.
IT IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN TAKE IN THE NORMAL COURSE OF
EVENTS RIGHT WOMEN WHO WHO OFTEN
WORK ALONE WHO ARE ACING --
SUPERVISORS -- SOMETIMES
MULTIPLE TIMES WHO WHO RAPE AND
ASSAULT THEM.
SO WHAT THE JANITORS I DID IN
FOLLOW UP TO THAT BILL IS A SAID
THAT'S GREAT THAT YOU CAN HAVE
AN ATTORNEY NOW COME TELL US OUR
RIGHTS BECAUSE SOME OF THE
PROBLEM WAS WE HAVE.
A LOT OF IMMIGRANT WORKERS TO
COME FORWARD AND SAY.
WE DON'T WE HAVE DIFFERENT
RIGHTS HERE.
WOULD WOULD WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WE DON'T HAVE TO BE
SUBJECT TO THAT SO WE HAVE A
RIGHT TO SPEAK UP. TO DEMAND --
TO NOT BE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED OR
RAPED OR HARASSED -- BUT THAT
THERE'S A DISCONNECT WHEN YOU
BRING IN AN ATTORNEY TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY IN A LANGUAGE THAT THEY
IN A CULTURE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
WHEN IN FACT WE CAN CREATE EIGHT
A NEW MODEL TO ALLOW JANITORS
THEMSELVES TO BE TRAINED AS A
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ON TO POWER
THEMSELVES AND TEACH EACH OTHER --
NOT ONLY HOW TO REPORT AN
UNDERSTAND ABUSE BUT ALSO HOW TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES -- AND SO IT'S
A MODEL PROGRAM THAT I THINK --
ONCE IMPLEMENTED COULD BE
EXPANDED IT'S BASED ON KIND OF A
PROMO TORA IDEA THAT YOU KNOW
THEY OF COURSE UNDERSTAND EACH
OTHER BETTER THEY WILL THEY WILL --
YOU TALK MORE WE WILL POWER
WORKERS IN A WAY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES BETTER AND IN THIS
INDUSTRY.
SO WITH THAT I WILL MOVE ON TO
MY WITNESSES.
THANK YOU JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
WE HAVE FIVE MINUTES BETWEEN THE
THREE THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
I HAVE. ONE OF THE YES SIR.
ANOTHER DISEASE IN THE LAWRENCE
MAJORA'S BUT DON'T.
MEAN I'M REMINDED TO HE ALWAYS
WITH A HUG OR NINE NINE DOES
TAKE ANYBODY ATWATER FROM THE
MOST.
BRING DANIELS.
US SENATORS WITH A MUCH RESPECT
THEY GREET YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MANY OF MY AFTER HE ON
I'VE BEEN A JANITOR IN THE THIS
INDUSTRY I WORK IN THIS.
INDUSTRY FOR THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS.
I MEAN FOR YOU NOT PROMOTE DORA
IT IS TO BE THE MOTHER IS A
SAINT SO WHAT DOES THE OPPOSITE
THAT'S YOUNG BUT I PUT IN THERE.
COMO IN SENIOR OUR PROGENITOR
COMPLETELY NEEDY THAN DIFFICULTY
REPORT THAT.
WNCL SIX ONLY LOW SEAT BECAUSE
IT BROUGHT BACK HOME.
I'M ALSO UP FROM THE BOTTOM AND
I RECEIVED I THINK I'M ALSO A
PROMOTE DONNA AND I RECEIVED
OVER SIXTY HOURS OF TRAINING. TO
LEARN HOW TO TEACH OTHER
JANITORS HOW TO PREVENT IDENTIFY
AND REPORT SEXUAL VIOLENCE AT
THE WORK SITE [inaudible]
NOSOTROS.
NO SOMEONE JENNY THIRTY SEVEN
ONE MILLION LUCAS LUCCO.
SS BUT A LIST OF IMPROVE THEIR
STUFF BUT SEE YOUR IN LAWS REYES
ROOMS.
ROY MOORE MAYBE THEY'LL THE UP
TO THE YOU KNOW A MOST OVER THE
VEHICLE.
US AS JANITORS WE KNOW VERY WELL
WHAT THE CULTURE IS.
A WITHIN THOSE WALLS.
THROUGH THOSE HALLWAYS AND IN
THE BREAK ROOM WE'VE LIVED IT
DAY AFTER DAY AND WE'VE SURVIVED
IT.
YOUR SAID YOUR ZIP BERMAN MADE
THE CASE HAS GLASSES A REMOTE
BORDERS.
NO FEELING UP ALL THOSE.
LAURA M. AND ONLY BE SPOKEN
THESE PROP YOURS OF COURSE LAYS
THOUGH YOU.
WHEN I CAMPAñA?
I KNOW PERSONALLY THAT THESE
CLASSES -- AS FROM ABOUT US
WORKS FOR EVERYONE I'VE SEEN IT
WITH MY OWN EYES AND I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE.
WE COMBINE YOU KNOW THAT THE OF
OUR HOLY I SEE A COMMON THIRTY
OWES I WITH A COMPANION US
ALREADY.
THROUGH SANDALS.
AREN'T ONE THOUGH A YOUNG LADY
OKAY PRADA YEAH BUT I DON'T IT
IS THE HOME PHONE.
PHONE.
ARE BROMUS.
NO NO NO THIRTY CM ANOTHER MODEL
WHEN A COWORKER OF MINE USED TO
MAKE COMMENTS TO A WOMAN -- I TO
ANOTHER COWORKER ABOUT HER
BREASTS AND SHE ASKED HIM TO
STOP HE SAID IT'S JUST A JOKE
I'M NOT SAYING ANYTHING WRONG.
IN THE SAID YOU ONLY BE THERE
LIKE WANT OTHER PROMOTE THOUGHT
US A YEAR UP IN THE HOME.
BACK ALSO YOUR SAMPLE SIX ONE
ONE THOUGH IT WILL BE OUT OF A
HOLE IN THE VIETNAM YEAH Là YET
THE NEEDLE FROM GRAHAM DEAL.
SO I INVITED HIM TO A PROMOTED
AS MEETING.
AND THERE HE LEARNED WHAT.
WAS THAT HE WAS DOING WAS SEXUAL.
HARASSMENT AND WHEN HE RETURNED
TO WORK HE HAD CHANGED GET
BECOME SOMEONE ELSE AND THE
WHOLE IN THE COURSE OF MY LIFE
SALAS COMPANION OF THE OCT ONE
GRADUALLY LIST GO TO HERE.
A LOS OTROS COMPANION HOST ONE
THOUGH THIS YOUNG FORCE US
ENOUGH IT'LL BE OTHER FROM YEMEN
AND WEBER THROW OUT COOL.
SO HE NOT ONLY CHANGED HIMSELF
BUT HE CORRECTED THE OTHER MEN
WHO SAID INAPPROPRIATE THINGS
AND HARASSED ARE FEMALE CO
WORKERS AS WELL.
AS HIS GET BUT UP ONE MILLION
ELECTORAL ACOSTA LEAVE YOUR LAN
SAYS SIX ONE AND THEN WHAT THAT
THAT OUR WHOLE.
INNERMOST GAS AND OIL FROM YOUR
THE OTHER INTRO PART OF WOOD ON
SO IN ORDER TO REALLY CHANGE --
THIS CULTURE OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AND HARASSMENT AT WORK WE HAVE
TO START FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
YOU KNOW SO CLOSE LOW SO WHAT
HAVE YOU YET THIS.
LAST PROMOTE ORDER FOR THE MOST
A ST LOUIS IS BY MOST TO KEEP IT
UP IN THE LIST.
SO WHAT ABOUT AMERICA OVER TO ME
THAT THE POOR OF THE FOURTEENTH
BUT I IF I THINK WE'LL SPEAK UP
BUT A LIST OF COMBINING IT OFF.
YOUR LAP AND HONEST AS YOU HAVE
SOME BE IT
FAMILY REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT WITH A
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING RAPE CRISIS CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND ALSO A
NATIONAL ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ENDING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
WHEREVER IT MAY OCCUR -- I
CONSIDERED A GREAT HONOR TO BE
TESTIFYING BEFORE YOU TODAY I'M
NOT JUST REPRESENTING HOW COSTS
IN FAVOR OF AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN
BUT ALSO AS A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA -- DEEPLY DEDICATED
TO SEEING VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR STATE AND ONCE
AND FOR ALL.
IT IS OFTEN WORK ALONE AT NIGHT
JANITORIAL WORKERS FACE A SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH MAKE THEM
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASSAULT AND
RAPE WHILE ON THE JOB.
BEING ISOLATED FROM CO WORKERS
IN THE PUBLIC REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING SOMEBODY
INTERVENE AS A WITNESS AND ALSO
REDUCE.
THE TO COME FORWARD TO SOMEBODY
YOU TRUST TO REVEAL WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ABUSE ASSAULT AND
RAPE WE KNOW WHAT CAL COSTS AND
WE KNOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PREVENTION CAN WORK.
THAT WE CAN PREVENT ABUSE AND
HARASSMENT BEFORE THEY EVER TAKE
PLACE AND IN AN ERA WHERE WE ARE
MORE CONSCIOUS THAN EVER OF THE
EFFECTS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF
THE IMPACT OF SEXUAL ABUSE.
AND ARE COMMITTED MORE THAN EVER
TO RESPONDING TO IT WE MUST MEET
THAT COMMITMENT WITH AN EFFORT
TO PREVENT THIS KIND OF
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE BEFORE
IT EVER OCCURS.
AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN DOES THAT IT
ENABLES THE WORKERS THEMSELVES
TO TRUST THEMSELVES COME
TOGETHER AND DEVELOP SOLUTIONS
FOR THEIR OWN INDUSTRY FOR THEIR
OWN COWORKERS AND FOR THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB.
FIVE FORTY SEVEN AND HUMBLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
FOR WE DO I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM SINCE WE DO HAVE ONE
PRESIDENT.
IF WE DO WITH THE COMMITTEE
ASSISTANCE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
MORALE.
WELL HERE JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
YEAH CAM HERE.
VERY GOOD WITH THE SEVEN FORM
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
RENEE BAYARDO SO YOU CALIFORNIA
RESPONSE FOR THE BILL AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MITCH DYER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SIR TO RURAL CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHE HARM HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
EVEN MY BROWN BAG OF ASKED ME
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YES FROM THE HAVE THE TEAMSTERS
IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANOTHER STORY PLEASE.
THE NUMBER IS NOT A SILLY YEAH I
AM SUPPORT SO YOU DON'T NEED
THEM.
MY NAME IS.
MY NAME IS CATALINA I AM JANITOR
AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NOW MOVED OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN MORNING MR
CHEN SENATORS THAT HAVE BECOME
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL -- AS A
PRELIMINARY MATTER THERE IS LOTS
OF REGULATORY AND LEGISLATIVE
WORK STILL BEING DONE ON THIS
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
SPENDING BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
MAKING CHANGES TO THIS SECTION
OF THE LAW THERE'S TWO SEPARATE
LABOR COMMISSIONER REGULATIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY PENDING ONE
ON JANITORIAL REGISTRATION ONE
ON THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING.
REQUIREMENTS AND THERE'S ALSO
DEPARTMENT FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ANY REGULAR.
I ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING
WHICH AUTHORIZED PEER TO PEER
TRAINING BUT DON'T NECESSARILY
MANDATE IT -- BUT OPEN THE DOOR
TO THAT CONCEPT AND SO.
WE THINK WE SHOULD ALLOW THE
DUST TO SETTLE ON THOSE
REGULATORY CHANGES BEFORE YOU
MOVE FORWARD -- WITH THIS BILL
AND WE KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
VETOED A SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR
AND SAID WE SHOULD ALLOW
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
BEFORE ENGAGING.
AND ACTING SIGNIFICANT CHANGES.
WITH RESPECT TO THE BILL ITSELF
WE HAVE TWO CONCENS NUMBER ONE
OF THE PROVISION THAT REQUIRES
APPLET.
SUBMIT INFORMATION RELATED TO A
BRANCH LOCATIONS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS AND EMPLOYEES OF
THOSE SUBCONTRACTORS.
WE THINK IT'S DIFFICULT FOR AN
APPLICANT NECESSARILY HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION AS TO THE EMPLOYEES
SO WE THINK THE PERIOD SHOULD
AND IN THAT SENSE WHERE YOU
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
BRANCH LOCATIONS IN THE SUB
CONTRACT.
BUT NOT NECESSARY CERTAINLY DOWN
TO THE LEVEL OF EMPLOYEES --
THIS CONCEPT IS CONTAINED IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S REGULATIONS
AS WELL AND WE RATE BASED
CONCERNS WITHOUT PROPOSAL NOT
PROCESS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PEER TO PEER
TRAINING MANDATE.
THIS BILL MANDATES YOU ONLY USE
A PROVIDER THAT'S ON A STATE
APPROVEDLIST AND YOU PROP
PROVIDE THEM TWICE THE MINIMUM
WAGE. TO DO TO DO THE TRAINING
AND WE THINK THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT THERE
MIGHT BE SOME I ASKED.
INTO UNION ORGANIZING AND WE
THINK IT'S JUST AN APPROPRIATE
TO DO IT THROUGH THIS CHANNEL
WHERE YOU HAVE TO PAY THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO TIME STATE
MINIMUM WAGE FROM A SPECIALIST
THAT'S ONLY APPROVED BY THE
STATE.
I THINK AUTHORS RAISED
LEGITIMATE ISSUES RELATED TO
CULTURAL COMPETENCY IN LANGUAGE
ISSUES FOR THIS UNIQUE.
GROUP OF WORKERS AND WE THINK
THOSE ARE LEGITIMATE ISSUES AND
WE THINK A CONVERSATION WE HAD
ABOUT WAYS TO BUILD.
THOSE.
CONTAINS THOSE COMPONENTS
WITHOUT MANDATING THAT COME FROM
A SPECIALIST OF ONLY STATE
APPROVED.
PROVIDERS AND SO WE'VE HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE SPONSOR
ABOUT -- ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATIONS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES WITHOUT DOING IT TO
A SPECIFIC MANDATED LIST.
I WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT AT THIS TIME
WERE POSTED. FOR YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SHE HELLO ANSWER THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION RIPOSTE
THANK YOU.
LOGIN SHAUN THOSE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF IN A BUSINESS FOR
BRING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO
PUT THANK YOU MISTER LEWIS
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN BRING IT ACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS.
BUT WE DO HAVE A MOTION IN THE I
JUST WANTED.
SENATOR ME.
ALRIGHT.
IT'S ALRIGHT YOU WHEN YOU ENTER
A ROOM IT'S ALWAYS ALLOWED
ENTRANCE UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
OF I JUST WANTED.
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON
THAT I MEAN IT'S A GREAT GREAT
BILL AND A GREAT IDEA AND
CERTAINLY IT.
JANITORIAL STAFF FOR THEIR
UNIQUELY VULNERABLE.
OF TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THE
TESTIMONY WAS AS PAINFUL TO HEAR.
WHEN YOU THINK OF PEOPLE PLACED
IN THOSE SITUATIONS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH NO CONTROL
AND AND IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AND EXPECTING SOMETHING?
I THINK THE THE OPPONENTS TO
MAKE.
I THINK A VALID POINT IN SOME
SENSE THAT THIS COULD FORCE THE
JANITORIALPOLICE. TO TWO
PLAYERS TO PAY FOR THE UNION
ORGANIZATION IN THE GUISE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING AND I
KNOW YOU'VE YOU'VE HEARD THAT
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE SO IT -- TO
A COULD CREATE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES WITH THE BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE IN SOME ISSUES
WITH THE REGULATIONS AND OF SO I
JUST.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT DEFINITION
WIDENED SOMEHOW SO I MEAN I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE THE THE THE
BILL SO THAT WE CAN.
PROTECT THOSE WERE I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S THE KEYS BUT I HOPE THE
YOU CAN SEE SOME DEFINITIONAL
CHAGES IN FROM BROADENING OF
THAT.
AND AND I TRULY SUPPORTED TODAY
AND HOPEFULLY WILL ON THE FLOOR
AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND IN YEAH
YOU MAY CLOSE IT I I JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR -- FIRST OF ALL AS
FAR AS TIMING.
YOU KNOW THIS IS ABOUT TRUSTING
THE WORKERS THE WORKERS CAME UP
WITH THE MOST OF IT WAY TO TEACH
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN DEFENSE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. TO EACH OTHER
I'M AND IN SO WHERE DO WE
ACTUALLY GET I'M THE BEST ADVICE
FROM WORKERS STATE THEY HAVE.
BEEN TRAINED THEY'RE NOT -- THAT
BY ALL MEANS THEIR UNION
ACTIVISTS RIGHT NOW THE TRAINING
IT ARE UNION MEMBERS BUT THEY'RE
NOT UNION STAFF THIS ISN'T UNION
STAFF GOING AN ENTRY IT'S ACTUAL
JANITORS SO.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON THAT YOU
KNOW IF IF NON UNION JANITORS --
HAD THE ABILITY AND AND I'M SURE
THAT THE UNION WOULD ALSO TRAIN
THEM AND AND PROVIDE THIS TYPE
OF OF EMPOWERMENT TO NON UNION
JANITORS WHO BY THE WAY THOUGH
ARE AT WILL EMPLOYEES AND AND
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO SPEAK
UP IN THE WORKPLACE SO WE CAN
HAVE.
A DISCONNECT THERE -- IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT EMPOWERING WORKERS
TO TALK TO EACH OTHER -- YOU
ALMOST HAVE TO BE UNION -- TO
PROVIDE A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
PROTECTION IN THAT WORK SO I I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE REALISTIC.
THE MOST OFFENSIVE THING THAT
THEY CONTINUE BRING UP IS IS THE
FACT THAT YOU'D HAVE TO TEACH
THESE TRAIN OUR PAY THESE
PRINTERS TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE
IN FACT IN OTHER COMMITTEES I
HEARD.
IT SHOULD BE DOING IT
VOLUNTARILY.
I WOULD CHALLENGE THEM TO FIND
AN ATTORNEY WHO TEACHES --
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE COST AS AS
VALUED AS TREISMAN WAGE YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S A TURNS OUT THERE WHO
COME IN AND TEACH THAT COURSE
FOR TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE I'D
BE SHOCKED.
PROBABLY WOULD HIRE THEM -- AND
AND LITERALLY TO IT TO SUGGEST
THAT THESE JANITORS DON'T
DESERVE COMPENSATION FOR THIS
WORK IT IS ALWAYS A LITTLE
OFFENSIVE.
WE'RE ALSO IN A VERY IMPORTANT
TIME PERIOD IN THAT -- THESE
REGULATIONS ARE BEING DEVELOPED
AND IF WE HAVE A MODEL THAT WE
CAN USE THAT IS WE WE BELIEVE
THE BEST MODEL IT'S TIME TO
INTERVENE RATHER THAN LET
ANOTHER MODEL BE STEP FORWARD.
AND HAVE TO COME IN THE SAME
ARGUMENTS WILL OF COURSE BE MADE
WE JUST DECIDED ON THIS MODEL
LET'S GIVE IT WHAT A YEAR TWO
YEARS FIVE YEARS HOW MANY WOMEN.
IN THAT PROCESS AND HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO SUBJECT THEMSELVES
TO ASSAULT AND RAPE WHILE WE LET
THE DUST SETTLE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD LET THE DUST
SETTLE.
I DON'T WANT THE DUST TO SETTLE
I WANT THESE WOMEN TO IT TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AND
SO I THINK THE TIME IS NOW I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK I'M.
WEAK ENOUGH FOR ME WHEN THEY
BROUGHT ME THIS BILL
[inaudible]
IF IT.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS THIS IS
PROBABLY HOW WE SHOULD APPROACH
WORK IN WORKERS IN TRAINING MORE
SO.
NOT THAT WE SHOULD BE SO AFRAID
OF WORKERS EMPOWERING THEMSELVES
IN BEING FROM A TODAS AND
TALKING TO EACH OTHER AND
ACTUALLY TEACHING THEM THE BEST
WAY THAT PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO
LEARN.
SO I THINK IT'S A MODEL PROGRAM
AND I I HOPE I'M GLAD YOU'LL BE
SPORTING AT MY HOPE IT CONTINUES
TO MOVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SENATOR PAN THANK YOU FOR THAT
THE OF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HILL HI
BILL AYE MORRELL [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE PAN
ALL RIGHT.
I WILL HAVE THREE THREE VOTES
WILL HOLD WILL OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
REMEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB.
FIVE EIGHTY NINE AS WE CONTINUE
ON MISTER CHAIR OF AMONG MY
BILLS THAT.
MADE IT THROUGH THE PROCESS LAST
YEAR ABOUT BE TOWED BY OUR
FORMER GOVERNOR.
I BRING YOU AB -- FIVE EIGHTY
NINE IT IS SPONSORED BY -- I
MUST SAY MY REPUBLIC CAN --
DISTRICT.
SAN DIEGO.
IN -- TWENTY SIXTEEN WE KNOW
THAT WHILE TWENTY SIXTEEN SANDIA
BASE COUPLE WAS ARRESTED FOR
INSULATING AN INDONESIAN
DOMESTIC WORKER IN THEIR HOME
FORCING HER TO WORK BETWEEN
SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN HOURS A DAY
WITH NO PAY AND NO DAYS OFF.
THE WAY -- EMPLOYERS ABUSE SO
OFTEN -- IMMIGRANTS IS THROUGH
SOMETHING WE CALL DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE THAT'S WHERE THEY
WITHHOLD THEIR DOCUMENTS WHICH
ALLOW THEM TO MOVE FREELY IN THE
UNITED STATES -- WITHOUT
REPUTATION AND AND DON'T PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO KNOW THAT EVEN IF
THEY'RE HERE ON A VISA OR IF
THEY HVE A PASSPORT OR IF THEY
HAVE A GREEN CARD THAT THEY THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR SOME PROTECTED
RIGHTS.
THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT WOULD --
SIMPLY -- INSURE THAT WORKERS
ARE ARE MADE AWARE OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND THAT -- THAT THAT THE
EMPLOYER MUST PROVIDE A WRITTEN
DOCUMENTATION TO THOSE VERY
BASIC RIGHTS THAT -- YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO OF COURSE BEING
PAID THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE
FORCED TO LIVE SOMEWHERE -- AND
THAT YOU YOU HAVE BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS THAT EXIST EVEN IF YOU'RE
BROUGHT HERE FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY TO DO -- SIR.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
VERY GOOD IT'S AMAZING HOW. ONE
WOULD NOT THINK THE BILL WOULD
<c.green>E NECESSARY.</c>
PLEASE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WANT TO RUN HEALTH
SEES ME COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
SAN DIEGO DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MARY ELLIN BARRETT.
THEN THE TEAM LEADER OF THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AREA OF OUR
OFFICE AND HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR ABOUT SEVEN YEARS.
IN MY TIME PROSECUTING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES I'VE SEEN AS
CRIME IT HAPPENS IN THE SHADOWS
I'VE SEEN.
THE TRAFFICKERS WITHHOLD
DOCUMENTS.
ALLOWING THE VISAS THEREAFTER TO
EXPIRE AND THEN HOLDING THAT.
LACK OF AUTHORIZATION OVER THE
HEAD.
OF THE VICTIM I HAVE.
HANDLED CASES WHERE THAT LINE OF
DEMARCATION IS WHEN THE X. AT
REAL HORRIBLE EXPLOITATION
BEGETS BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
HAVE THEM.
I FOUND OFTEN THAT ARE ARE
VICTIMS DO NOT KNOW -- OUR
SYSTEM OF LAWS OUR LAWS -- HOW
ARE LAWS ARE ENFORCED HOW ARE
POLICE WORK WHAT THE WORKERS
RIGHTS ARE OR EVEN THAT THERE
WERE?
FORTY WHEN THEY'RE FOREIGNERS IN
OUR COUNTRY.
THEY'RE OFTEN MANIPULATED BY THE
TRAFFICKER WHO EXPLAINS OUR
SYSTEM TO HIS OR HER ADVANTAGE.
FOR EXAMPLE.
I'LL TAKE YOUR DOCUMENTS AND
KEEP THEM SAFE.
AND YOU CANNOT GO OUTSIDE
WITHOUT YOUR DOCUMENTS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THEM AT ALL TIMES.
WELL THAT'S THAT'S NOT TRUE.
COUNTRY BUT BUT THE WORKERS
DON'T KNOW THAT.
THAT IS ANOTHER WAY TO BOTH
CONTROL AND ISOLATE THE VICTIMS
IF THEY THINK THEY CAN'T GO OUT.
WE KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
BECAUSE THE THE NATIONAL STUDY
71% OF OF TRAFFICKING LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS ENTER THE
COUNTRY.
AUTHORIZED AND BY THE TIME THE
VICTIMIZATION DISCOVERED 69% OF
THEM.
IT THE ARE ON AUTHORIZED.
SO IT'S GOING ON LANGUAGE IS A
RED FLAG IN VICTIMIZATION OF
THIS.
THE INABILITY TO SPEAK ENGLISH
INCREASES THE CHANCES OF
VICTIMIZATION THIS BILL.
EXPLAINS THE RIGHTS IN THE
NATIVE LANGUAGE OF THE WORKER
WHICH WILL HELP EDUCATE AND
PROTECT THEM GOING FORWARD.
THIS BILL WILL SHINE A LIGHT FOR
ALL WORKERS ON THE LIES THAT THE
TRAFFICKERS USED TO CONTROL AND
MANIPULATE THEIR VICTIMS.
PROVIDE A TOOL TO EDUCATE THE
WORKERS ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS AND
TO PROTECT THEM AGAINST THE FEW
UNSCRUPULOUS EMPLOYERS WHO WOULD
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEM.
AS WELL AS A TOOL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HOLD THOSE OF
EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE AND STOP
THIS CRIME TO STOP IT AT THE
BEGINNING.
STAGES BEFORE IT MOVES IN TO THE
FULL BLOWN LABOR.
TAKING AND THE DEVASTATION THAT
THAT CALLED SINCE.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STUFF IN AS A
SPONSOR THIS BILL AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR IN LIGHT.
IN LIGHT NEED US ON THE SUBJECT
IN THE THANK YOU BRING THAT
FORWARD OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FOR
SEPTEMBER HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE DO BELIEVE THE EXPLOITATION
OF WORKERS IN HUMANE AND I'M
JUST ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO SEIU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK.
WHICH DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TAKE A BREAK OR NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORK
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EVEN WEBER ASKED ME CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ANDRE RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
YOU'D LIKE.
TO TAKE A SEAT TERM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
ROBERT MUTRIE ON DEATH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
I'M AND WE ARE OPPOSED.
I'D LIKE TO BE CLEAR ABOUT OUR
GROUNDS.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE NOT IN SUPPORT
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING OR TAKING
SOMEONE'S DOCUMENTS TO DO YOU
KNOW TO TO KEEP THEM INSERTED
INTO TERRIBLE THINGS.
TO ABSOLUTELY NOT -- WHILE WE'RE
HERE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO THANK
THE AUTHORIZED TO ONE SPECIFIC
POINT IN THE WORKERS BILL OF
RIGHTS WHICH WILL BE DRAFTED AS
A RESULT WHICH WILL TO WORK
TOGETHER ON TO RESOLVE THE M. --
WHAT EXACTLY WAS THE WORKERS
RIGHT TO LIVE ANYWHERE AND TO
CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE SO WE
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THAT?
I'M WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
FOR ALMOST THE REASON AS AS YOU
REFERENCE THAT GOVERNOR BROWN
VETO IT THIS LAST YEAR RIGHT AND
I LIKE ALL USES LANGUAGE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIAN
PLAYERS HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
LABOR TRAFFICKING AND SO THIS
MANDATE AS APPLIED TO THEM IS
BURDENS AND ON WARRANTED.
WE KNOW WE SHARE THE CONCERNS WE
WE THAT IS OUR CONCERN HERE THAT --
ANOTHER DOCUMENT ANOTHER SEE
EACH OTHER MAINTAINED RECORD --
AND TRANSLATION IS IS A BURDEN
ON EVERY SINGLE EMPLOYER IN THE
STATE FROM.
I'M A SMALL GROCERY STORE IN
EUREKA TO YOU KNOW THE SALES
FORCE TOWER.
AS FAR AS THAT RANGE GUNS.
NOT OPPOSED TO THE CORE CONCERNS
HERE AND AND ABSOLUTELY.
I'M ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
STAFF FOR THE THOROUGH ANALYSIS
AND FOR NOTING THAT THERE
ALREADY.
THANKFULLY -- FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS PROHIBITING MISCONDUCT --
YOU KNOW THERE MAYBE BURDEN IT.
MAKE IT BETTER PROSECUTE
APPOINTED YEAH THAT'S ACTUALLY.
YOUR PLACE BUT THANK STAFF
ANALYSIS.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
OTHERS HERE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SEEING NO [inaudible]
ONE SORRY.
KATIE HANSON RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION RUSSELL POST.
THANK YOU ASCENSION ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
I BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS CONCERNS QUESTION.
WE DO.
WANT TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SURE I'M A A RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE DON'T KNOW WHICH
EMPLOYERS ARE ENGAGED IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING I MEAN IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF WE COULD SAY.
THIS IS A GOOD EMPLOYER THIS IS
A BAD EMPLOYER THE RULES ONLY
APPLY TO THE BAD EMPLOYERS --
BUT WE JUST CAN'T DO THAT IN
THIS IS SUCH.
I THINK -- SCAR ON NOT JUST OUR
CURRENT -- LABOR PRACTICES BUT
ON OUR HISTORY IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT IT WARRANTS --
WORKERS TO UNDERSTAND THE RIGHT
IN THEIR LANGUAGE OF CHOICE.
IT WARRANTS -- A VERY SMALL
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS TO TO
MAINTAIN DOCUMENTS SO THAT -- SO
THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
ACTUALLY GO IN AND ASK FOR THOSE
DOCUMENTS AND THAT IT CAN.
IT CAN BE THE GATEWAY INTO
APPROVING ON THE THIRD DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE OR THE WORKERS WERE
BEING HELD -- WITHOUT WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT IN A SITUATION SO --
YOU KNOW THIS WAS BROUGHT TO US
BY I THINK THE DA WHO IS VERY
INTERESTED IN PROSECUTING THIS
CASE IS AND I WHICH WOULD HAVE
MORE DAYS WHO WERE THAT'S
INTERESTED.
I'M BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST WAIT
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
COME IN -- THEY LARGELY COME IN
ON BIG CASES WITH I AM LARGE
EMPLOYERS A SELDOM COMMAND ON ON
THE INDIVIDUAL -- SMALL SMALLER
CASES THAT WE FIND THIS TYPE OF
ABUSE IN AS WELL SO RESPECT LAST
NIGHT.
THANK YOU AND IN A MY
UNDERSTANDING IS OF ISSUE THIS
IS NOT JUST SPECIFIC TO SAN
DIEGO OR THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PORTS OF ENTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
ANYWHERE AND MY EXPECTATION IS
THAT THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CLOTHES WE DO HAVE A MOTION
TO PASS TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FROM SENATOR MITCHELL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL I HELLO I'M AROUND
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE PAN.
CAN I DO A THREE BY THREE VOTES
WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WILL NOW MOVE.
I REMEMBER TWELVE A. B. --
FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THIS IS ACTUALLY MY FIRST TIME
OF PRESENTING THIS BILL WAS
PERCENT WAS PULLED OFF CONSENT
SO AT THIS IS I THINK A FAIRLY
SIMPLE BILL I HAD A CONSTITUENT
COME TO ME.
WHO -- SHE SHE PUT MONEY HER OWN
MONEY INTO AN FSA HIRE EMPLOYER
THE EMPLOYER BY FEDERAL LAWS
REQUIRED TO NOTIFY HER ONCE WHEN --
THE TIME PERIOD FOR UTILIZING
HER OWN WAGES -- WOULD WOULD
EXPIRE AND THAT'S REVERT BACK TO
THE EMPLOYER -- THEY NOTIFIED
HER BY EMAIL IT CUTS BEYOND AN
INBOUNDS BACKED SO SHE CAME TO
ME WITH AN IDEA OF CAN THEY AT
LEAST NOTIFY YOU TWICE.
YOU KNOW A SIMPLE IDEA TO ALLOW
WORKERS -- TO UTILIZE OF COURSE
THAT MONEY THAT THEY PUT AWAY
THAT IS THEIR MONEY THAT THEY
AREN'T AND AND TO ENSURE THAT
THEY AT THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE NOTIFICATION IN TIME
PERIOD SO THAT THEY CAN.
ACQUIRE VERY REASONABLE THANK
YOU.
ANYONE IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
YES HI ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SURE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
IN THE ONE SENATOR MITCHELL.
I WAS JUST CURIOUS -- HAVING
BEEN VERY CLOSE TO BE IN THAT
SITUATION MYSELF IN THE NUMBER
OF TIMES -- AND THERE.
SF THE F. S. A. ALLOWABLE.
SAVING FIFTY WILK CHILD CARE
HEALTH AND SO DOES YOUR BILL
ONLY COVER DEPENDED FOR ALL OF
THEM THAT FALL UNDER FSA.
I BELIEVE IT IT -- IT DOES COVER
ALL OF THEM IF IT'S MEANT TO IF
NOT I WILL MAKE SURE IT DOES
EXCELLENT I JUST.
SEEM TO ME THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
ALL ABOUT.
IT WAS INDEPENDENT BECAUSE IT'S
HEALTH BUT HOW WILL THEY BE AND
NOW THAT I WILL HAVE TO BUT I
JUST THOUGHT.
SHE CAME TO ME IT WAS A A CHILD
CARE ACCOUNT OF COURSE SHE'S A
SINGLE MOM WHO YOU KNOW I GET IT
HAS THE CELLS HAVING PAID THAT'S
I WAS I WAS HER.
I'M HAVING PAID INTO THAT
ACCOUNT FOR MY SON'S ENTIRE.
TRIAL TODAY -- BUT THIS OCCURRED
TO ME THERE ARE MULTIPLE F. S.
A. ACCOUNT HEALTH.
CARE.
WILL BE GREAT IF IF YOU DON'T
MIND IF IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE-PROCESS AND THE FIGHT HEALTH AS
WELL I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ADD
THAT OKAY GREAT.
I THINK IT WOULD HELP EMPLOYERS
TO BECAUSE THEN THEY DON'T HAVE
TO NOTIFY TWICE JUST FOR ONE
RIGHT IF THEY OFFER BOTH LIKE
THIS LIKE THE STATE SENATE.
THAT'S CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE.
SOMETHING IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
I KNOW APPROPRIATIONS LEVEL YOU
EXPAND BILLS AND YES.
WE'LL HAVE A GOOD TALK.
WELL IF IT'S GOING TO COST BILL
A PROBLEM THEN DON'T DO IT BUT
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME.
IT WOULD BE A WIN WIN ON ALSO
SENSE THANK YOU YOU HAVE A GOOD
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WOULD WITH
THE MESSAGE WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
IN THE AND THE POLICY WOULD
REDUCE DEVILISH.
I THINK THAT'S WONDERFUL
CERVANTES COMMENT I GUESS THE
AND I SAW THAT ALSO IT'S CLEAR
IF I COULD YOU SAID NOTIFY TWICE
ACTUALLY IT'S TWO DIFFERENT
FORMS AND ADVOCATE YES THANK YOU
KNOW IT TOO BECAUSE IN FACT IN
THIS THE SITUATION I LIKE TO
EMAIL SWITCH BOTH WILL HAVE. TO
COULD GO DOWN NOW.
IN IN A LOT OF EMPLOYERS ALREADY --
USE THAT POLICY INTERNALLY IT'S
IT'S JUST THAT THERE ARE SOME
WHO ABIDE BY THE LETTER OF THE
FEDERAL LAW WHICH DOESN'T
REQUIRE IT OKAY WELL HAVING TO
MOVE THE BILL.
WILL MAKE SURE THAT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR PANDA THIS
WILL BE.
DRIVERS WOULD LIKE CLOTHES I'M I
JUST WANT TO THANK.
THE REPUBLICANS FROM POINT IT SO
WE COULD ACTUALLY MAKE A BETTER
LIFE SO THERE IS A CLASS FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE FOR
THE CLOSE THIS IS THE MOTION BY
SENATOR PENN DO BEST
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE LEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE MORALE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I YEAH.
WILL THE ROLE OF REBEL MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
RECREATED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS HERE [inaudible]
WE WILL.
WE CAN.
WE WILL OF ONE SEVEN THANK YOU.
WE DO NEED A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB ONE SEVEN WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM US SENATOR PAN ON
AB ONE SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SENATOR HILL
AYE HILL AYE MORALE.
WORLD NO JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE PAN.
I BILL HAS THREE VOTE TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND NOW WE
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
NINETEEN WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR FAN PLEASE -- CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATOR HILL AYE.
HILL AYE MORALE.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE PAN.
PAN I FEEL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBER AS WELL SO THANK YOU.
SOMEONE IS.
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WAS THIS SEE YOU.
BACK.
AND WE WILL A
I SEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUTH
[inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
COME FORWARD.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO SIXTY
SEVEN WELCOME [inaudible]
OKAY -- PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE READY TO TAKE
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
SENATORS -- I'M HERE TO PRESENT
A. B..
TWO SIXTY SEVEN AVAIL WHICH
EXPAND HEALTH PROTECTION FOR
BABIES WORKING IN TELEVISION AND
MOVIES. TWO BABIES START WORKING
IN ALL ENTERTAINMENT.
AS THE EXCELLENT ANALYSIS NOTED
CALIFORNIA.
HOUSES LARGEST LARGEST LATER IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT REQUIRING
A DOCTOR'S PERMISSION BEFORE AN
INFANT.
YOUNGER THAN ONE MONTH OF CAN
WORK ON ANY TELEVISION OR MOTION
PICTURE ACT.
IN THIS ERA OF ONLINE.
AND STREAMING VIDEO AND MOBILE
ENTERTAINMENT CONTENT.
THE INFANT START OF YOU TO
NETFLIX AND INSTAGRAM.
MUST BE BROUGHT UNDER THE SAME
PROTECTION OF THE LAW.
SO I WILL I WILL ACCEPT YOU
PROPOSE TO MAMMON.
IN THIS COMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE
THE DEFINITION OF ENTERTAINMENT.
OFFER INDIANAPOLIS'S.
WHAT IS YOUR CHAIR AND THE STAFF
WILL WORKING WITH -- WITH MY
STAFF IN MY OFFICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO APPRECIATE
THAT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
IN A GOOD. FOR YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONVERSATION
DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM THE SENATE
COMMISSION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YEARS VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR MITCHELL -- TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IS AMENDED YES THANK YOU.
SENATOR HILL I FEEL I'M MORALE
[inaudible]
I JACKSON.
MITCHELL. FIVE MITCHELL AYE PAN.
WHAT THE ROLE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
YOUR RIGHT TO ENTER TOMORROW
YEAH OKAY WE HAVE. THREE THREE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND REMEMBER.
TO TWENTY IS GOING TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH THE VOTE
WE CAN ALWAYS GO BACK IN.
AND MAKE THOSE CHANGES --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SORRY
WE'RE IN FILE ORDER HERE SO --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER BUT WE
WILL GO ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
GOOD ST HADN'T SIT SAID DOWN YET
SO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WELCOME.
I THINK HIS IS A PRETTY FAST
EASY BILL.
THEY'RE ALL EASY AREN'T THEY YES
THEY ALSO I HOWEVER THREE AB
THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FORTY SIX
CORRECTS AND EQUITY IN EXISTING
LAW WERE LAUSD SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS.
RECEIVE A WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTION.
FORTY FIFTY ANOTHER SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS DO NOT.
COME REFER TO AS FORTY FIFTY
TIME IS TEMPERATE.
AND IF IT PROVIDES POLICE
OFFICERS WITH UP TO A YEAR PAID
LEAVE DEFENDER IN LINE OF DUTY.
TWENTY FIFTEEN FIVE POINT 2% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THREATEN OUR WITH A WEAPON OR
STUFF ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
PLEASE AUTHORS MUST RESTORE LIFE
TO PROTECT STUDENTS AND STAFF.
TO PROVIDE OF THE SAME BENEFITS
IF INJURED ON THE JOB.
MATH PROTECTION TO LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS WERE INJURED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
WE'RE GOOD WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THREE FIFTY GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CENTER PERERA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER SAID
AB THREE FORTY SIX CORRECTION
INEQUITY IN CURRENT LAW WERE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS
ARE THE ONLY SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS.
INCLUDED IN LABOR CODE SECTION.
FORTY EIGHT FIFTY ARE ALL JUST
ADD THAT THIS ISSUE CAN HAS NOT
BEEN RESOLVED THROUGH THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING ROCESS
DESPITE THE BEST EFFORTS OF
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND THEY
DESERVE EQUAL TREATMENT UNDER
THE LAW.
SO FOR EXAMPLE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT USED TO PROVIDE FORTY
EIGHT FIFTY TIME TO IT SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS UNTIL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ON THE DISTRICT OF THE
BENEFIT AWAY.
DISTRICT JUSTIFY THIS ACTION BY
POINTING TO THE EXACT IN EQUITY
AND LEAVE. SIX TO REMEDY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED.
US DIEGO UNIFIED PROVIDES ITS
OFFICERS WITH FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
TIME NOT AS A RESULT OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
BUT BECAUSE OF A WORKERS COMP
APPEALS BOARD DECISION THAT
FOUND A SCHOOL POLICE OFFICER
WAS ENTITLED TO FORTY EIGHT
FIFTY TIME.
SO BY ADDING ALL SCHOOL POLICE
OFFICERS TO LADY LABOR CODE.
FORTY EIGHT FIFTY AB THREE FORTY
SIX WILL ENSURE THAT ALL SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS RECEIVE THIS
VALUABLE BENEFIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFFREY LEE **** ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS
BENEFIT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION CASE OF GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STATE FOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES AND ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND OUR COLLEAGUES
AT SEA SAKE I A HERE TODAY AND
VERY RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AT
THE BE. THREE FORTY SIX I'D LIKE
TO START BY SHARING OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE AUTHORS --
OFFICE THE SPONSOR IN THE
GENEROUS WITH THEIR TIME HEARING
OUR CONCERNS.
AB THREE FORTY SIX PROPOSES
EXPANDING THE CLASS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY WORKERS ELIGIBLE FOR
LABOR CODE. FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
BENEFITS THAT INCLUDES FULL
SALARY CONTINUATION FOR ONE FULL
YEAR FREE OF STATE AND FEDERAL
TAXES FOR EACH INJURY THEY OCCUR
IN THE LINE OF DUTY. FORTY EIGHT
EIGHT FIFTY BENEFITS ARE IN LIEU
OF TD BENEFITS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED TO THESE INJURED
WORKERS.
THE GOAL OF THE TV BENEFIT IS TO
APPROXIMATE THE IN PLACE TAKE
HOME PAY DURING THE PERIOD AFTER
INJURY WHEN THE EMPLOYEE IS
TEMPORARILY UNABLE TO WORK.
THE GOAL IS IMPLEMENTED BY
BASING THE WEEKLY TV BENEFIT ON
TWO THIRDS OF THE EMPLOYEES
AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGES BUT BECAUSE
THE BENEFIT IS ALSO TAX FREE
MOST EMPLOYEES RECEIVE A
SUFFICIENT TV BENEFIT THAT'S
CLOSE TO THEIR TAKE HOME PAY
WHILE THEY'RE RECOVERING.
OUR GOAL IS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS IS
TO HELP OUR INJURED WORKERS
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE EVIDENCE
BASED MEDICAL CARE FOR THEIR
ILLNESSES AND INJURIES AND THEN
TO HELP THEM RETURN TO WORK AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. FORTY EIGHT
FIFTY CREATES A DISINCENTIVE OF
RETURNING TO WORK EVEN IF
THEY'RE ABLE DUE TO THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE OF MAKING
NORMAL TAKE HOME PAY PLUS WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN PAID IN TAXES.
AND WHILE ABUSIVE FORTY EIGHT
FIFTY MAY NOT BE INTENTIONAL IT
IS A REALITY.
UNDER THIS BILL PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
ALSO FACE HIGHER OVERTIME COSTS
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT FILL THE
POSITION OF AN OFFICER. FORTY
EIGHT FIFTY TIME BUT THEY STILL
HAVE TO COVER THOSE CHEFS THIS
IS AT GREAT EXPENSE NOT JUST TO
THE EMPLOYER BUT TO THE
REMAINING STAFF WHO MUST WORK
LONG HOURS TO COMPENSATE LOSS OF
THE MISSING OFFICER.
GOOD JOB IT IS NOT LEAVE THAT
THE NECESSARY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO JUSTIFY ALL SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR TIME ON THE JOB OR THEIR
ACTUAL DUTIES PERFORMED A
RECEIVING THE SAME GENEROUS
BENEFIT IS ACTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
LOCAL AGENCIES TYPICALLY FIND
WORKERS COMPENSATION COSTS OUT
OF THEIR GENERAL FUND THROUGH
NONPROFIT PUBLIC ENTITY GPAS AND
EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON SPECIAL
ENHANCE BENEFITS MUST COME FROM
SOMEWHERE.
AND FUNDING FOR THE SPECIAL
BENEFITS PROPOSING AB THREE
FORTY SIX WILL COME OUT OF
EDUCATION BUDGETS AND WILL
SUBTRACT FROM CLASSROOMS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY EXAMINE
BOTH THE JUSTIFICATION AND THE
COST OF THIS PROPOSAL.
BUT AT THIS TIME WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL FOR THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED ONE THANK
YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION JEAN
AND BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR RECESSION YES SENATOR I'LL
MOVE THE BILL IN THE SUPPORTING
THE PARTICULARS OF THAT IMPACTS
LA U. S. THE THAT I REPRESENT --
DO HAVE A CONCERN IN THIS IS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE.
REYES HERE BUT IN FISCAL
COMMITTEE -- SINCE PROPER E.
FAILED IN LOS ANGELES.
THE ISSUE IS HOW WILL BE PAID.
FOR TEACHERS STRIKING BILL UST
IS VERY PUBLICLY BEEN IN VERY
DIRE FINANCIAL -- STRAIGHT.
AGAIN WITH THE BALLOT INITIATIVE --
ANGELENOS DIDN'T SUPPORT IT WILL
BE A CONCERN IN TERMS OF HOW
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS DAYS OF
WELL I THINK IT.
IS A RELEVANT ISSUE TO RAISE
JUST IN TERMS OF AFFORDABILITY --
BUT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT ON THE
ON THE STRENGTH OF THE POLICY
TODAY SOME OF THE BILL.
WE THANK YOU AN INSIDE A TO SIT
LIKE THE I JUST TO SUPPORT THE
POLICY IDEAS.
BASICALLY THESE ARE SWORN PEACE
OFFICERS AND THEY SHOULD RECEIVE
THIS.
WHICH IS OTHER TOWARD HIS
OFFICERS AND COULD NOT BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE OF
THAT HAPPY BUT CERTAINLY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AS WELL.
OTHER COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WHENEVER WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR.
MITCHELL TO MOVE THE BILL TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATOR HILL AYE
HILL AYE MORRELL [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
HI MITCHELL AYE.
THE WHOLE THE ROLE OF A FRESH
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
APPRECIATED WILL NOW MOVE I SAW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DATE.
IN THE ROOM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
I WAS PULLING FOR YOU OVER HERE.
REMEMBER DALY IT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY THREE FIFTY FIVE
GOOD MORNING.
WE ARE WE ARE.
YOUR LOCAL I. SO MUCH ALIKE THAT
WAY.
I TO REVIVE AB FOR FIFTY SAID
I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER FOUR OF
FOUR EIGHTY THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE PROCEED THANK THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
CURRENTLY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD.
PUBLIC AGENCIES NOT COVERED BY
PER LABOR DISPUTES ARE OFTEN
CONTEST IN THE COURT ROOM WHICH
CAN BE COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING.
I CONTRAST CURBS EXPERTISE IN
LABOR RELATIONS LAW OFFERS
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AN
EXPEDITIOUS AND COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE. TO JUDY.
PLACE DISPUTES THIS BILL SIMPLY
ADDS THE ORANGE TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. TO THAT VAST MAJORITY
OF AGENCIES ALREADY COVERED
UNDER PER THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES.
WITH ME TODAY SHANE GOODMAN
REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS UNION
THERE IS SPONSORING.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS -- WE
DO -- STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL --
IT ARE WE HAVE I THINK
PROXIMALLY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AT
C. T. -- AND THE UNION.
FEELS VERY STRONGLY THAT THIS IS
AN APPROPRIATE MOVE -- SO THAT
WE CAN SAVE COST IF A DISPUTE
SHOULD ARISE -- I WANT SAID THAT
THERE'S A TON ADDITION.
THE EMPLOYER -- BUT WHEN THEY'RE
THERE IS A DISPUTE ON UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE AND YOU DO HAVE
TO GO TO COURT IT CAN BE VERY
EXPENSIVE FOR BOTH SIDES AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY -- CT A IS IS
IS NOT OPPOSING THE BILL BECAUSE
IT'S EXPENSIVE FOR THE EMPLOYER.
TO AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
POINTED OUT PER PASS.
JURISDICTION AND THE EXPERTISE
TO HANDLE THESE KINDS OF CASES
AND LASTLY I WOULD NOTE OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS PER BASSETT HAD
INCREASED FUNDING -- SO THAT
THEY CAN HANDLE -- SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY'VE HAD IN THE
PAST IN TERMS OF BACKLOG I DON'T
THINK THAT'S AN ISSUE ANYMORE
AND THINK ADDING ONE AGENCY.
WILL NOT HAVE THAT KIND OF
IMPACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
WHICH DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THE NO ONE IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE HERE. TO THE COMMITTEE.
FOR COMMENT CONCERNED I'M I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT SLUTION
OBVIOUSLY THEY DO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN IT'S A WONDERFUL
WAY THAT.
OPPORTUNITY THE GOAL OF
CONSOLIDATING LABOR CONTRACT
RELATION DISPUTES THROUGH
PURPOSE.
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I THINK THE
POLICY GOALS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION [inaudible]
SENATE MITCHELL.
YOUR WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT SO MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
AND I WILL.
APPRECIATE IT AND I VOTE THANK
YOU YOU HAVE A MOTIONS TO DO
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THIS
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL.
WELL NO JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI.
THE ROLE OF THE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
FINALLY.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB.
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN TRYING TO KEEP
THINGS MOVING FOR YOU.
YOU'RE SUCH A GOOD CHAIR SIR.
ALL RIGHT.
SO CHAIR AND SENATE.
ALL RIGHT MAY BE.
AB FOR FIVE SEVEN REQUIRES THE
STANDARDS BOARD TO FINALIZE AND
ADOPT.
REGULATIONS THE PROPOSED TO
LOWER OCCUPATIONAL LEAD EXPOSURE
LEVELS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION AND
GENERAL INDUSTRY REGULATIONS.
HELLO SHE BEGAN WORKING ON
REVISING THESE REGULATIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THEY
RELEASED DRAFT REGULATIONS IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT THE
REGULATION IS YET TO BE ADOPTED.
EIGHT YEARS IS TOO LONG TO WAIT.
LEGISLATURE WILL BE SENDING A
STRONG MESSAGE THAT THE
REGULATIONS NEED TO BE COMPLETED.
SO WE CAN PROTECT WORKERS FROM
UNNECESSARY AND ON LEAD EXPOSURE --
I DON'T DO I HAVE THE EXPERT
WITNESS I GUESS.
NOW.
IT'S FINE THAT WE SHE'S AN
EXPERT.
MY STE MY STAFF THIS IS AN ALL
EXPERTS THE STAFF PEOPLE WE HAVE
YEAH EXACTLY WE SHE'S THANK GOD
SHE SHE IS THE LIVING EMBODIMENT.
OF WHAT WE SHOULD DO ABOUT LED
REGULATION.
LET ME TELL YOU THAT'S VERY GOOD
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS -- DON
GUN BEHALF THE WESTERN HOCKEY.
THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION -- WE
WERE AMONG THE ORIGINAL
PETITIONERS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN TO HAVE THE LEAD STANDARD
REVISED -- THERE'S NOTHING
ADVENTUROUS ABOUT THE STANDARD
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED -- THE
SCIENCE ISN'T IN DISPUTE.
IT WILL ALREADY BE A LITTLE BIT
OUT OF DATE IN OUR OPINION --
THE FACT THAT IT'S TAKEN ALMOST
TEN YEARS TO GET TO WHERE WE ARE
NOW.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
DEPARTMENT THAT DIVISION -- I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A VERY GOOD
REASON PORT.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING CAME THE ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
HI GOOD MORNING I'M ANTI MINETTI
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL FLAVORS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
YES.
SORRY TO MUSCLE IN ON YOU HERE
AT SCHEDULE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR --
SENATORS ROBERT MAJI FOR THE CAL
COMMERCENTRE SORRY O TURN MY
BACK KEY PRESIDENTIAL.
IT'S ALWAYS EMBARRASSING -- SO.
WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED US THIS
BILL AND FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND PAGE -- FOR
SPRING A LOT OF TIME TALKING TO
US ABOUT THIS AND WORKING OUR
CORE CONCERN HERE IS NOT -- YOU
KNOW PREVENTING LED REGULATIONS
COMING UP PIPER STOPPING THEM --
YOU KNOW THESE REGULATIONS ARE A
LONG TIME COMING AND I'M IN A
MOMENT I'LL TRY TO EXPLAIN THAT
BECAUSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WE'RE ALL UNDERSTANDING BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME ISSUES WITH
ACCELERATING ALWAYS.
BUT JUST THAT WE ENSURE THERE IS
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE STANDARDS
BOARD WHICH IS IT DISTINCT
PORTION RIGHT IT AND CAL OSHA
WAS NOT HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT
THIS THE SAME WAY.
AS THE PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE THE TIME TO LOOK AT IT MAKE
ANY AMENDMENTS THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE AND THE TIME.
FOR INTEREST GROUPS TO SPEAK AT
THAT POINT.
SO THAT'S OUR CONCERN -- TWO
EIGHT YOU MAY EXPLAIN THE
DISTINCTION RIGHT WE AGREE THAT
THE EIGHT YEAR DELAY HERE AT IS
CONSIDERABLE IN FACT THE ENTIRE
TO LIVE.
THESE LEAD REGULATIONS BEEN
PLACE FIFTY OR SO YEARS OUT OF
DATE WHICH ITSELF IS PROBLEMATIC --
BUT AS THE LATE IN THIS PROCESS
READ THE DIVISION TOOK I BELIEVE
AROUND SIX YEARS I RECALL
CORRECTLY TO COME OUT WITH THE
PROPOSED STANDARDS.
AND THEN THE ECONOMIC ANALYSIS
THE SERIE A WHICH IS DONE AFTER.
AND IT'S COME OUT.
I WAS ALSO MUCH LONGER INCOMING
THAT ANYBODY $TED
CAME OUT OF BELIEVE TWO THREE
WEEKS AGO AROUND THERE.
OKAY WAS A COMMENT I WOULD.
OKAY I WAS ONLY HIGHLY BUT
ARRIVING PUBLIC RELEASED AT THAT
POINT BUT RECENTLY TO THE THE
POINT IS THAT THIS PROCESS
HASN'T GONE TO THE STANDARDS
BOARD AND THE STANDARDS WHAT
HASN'T BEEN THE BODY DELAYING
THE DIVISION AND ANY KIND OF
CONTRACT TO PREP THE SERIE A
HAVE BEEN.
DELAYED AND WE WE AGREE THAT'S
REGRETTABLE WE JUST DON'T
BELIEVE THE STANDARD POOR'S
PROCESS WHICH IS SEPARATE SHOULD
BE RUSHED FOR THAT REASON.
AND AS TO THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
REGULATIONS IF YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
I'VE I'VE READ IN SOME DETAIL
THE PRETTY LENGTHY I'M I'M GLAD
TO TRY TO BE HELPFUL.
THE DETAILS OF EVERITT ISSUE BUT
THAT'S YES OF I AGREE IT'S AN
ISSUE OF TIMING -- AND AS TO THE
EXTENT OF THE CHANGE JUST TO
RESPOND BRIEFLY TO ONE OF THE
COMMENTS MADE.
THE EXTENDED CHANGES REGULATIONS
IS CONSIDERABLE WE'RE TALKING
THAT 80% REDUCTIONS IN THE
AMOUNT OF PRESS PRESS OF A LEAD
AS WELL AS SOME SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO THE MECHANICS.
SO THAT IS NOT TO SAY WE ARE
AGAINST THEM YOU KNOW BUT JUST
AS IT IS A SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE
FOR DESERVES THE TIME. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED MUST
AMENDED BUT WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
DEFINITELY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ONE SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DEAL GIVE US FOR THE
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SO STATION.
COMMENTS FOR THAT OF THE CHAMBER
OF WITH THAT OPPOSE LAST MINUTE
SESSION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
NO ONE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN NONE.
OF THE BILL.
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION I I
MEAN I THINK.
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF TIME I MEAN
AND IF WE CAN PUT WHATEVER
PRESSURE.
CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN I THINK
THAT.
YEAH AND IT IS PRESSURE IF.
IF.
YOUR OTHER HEELS A LAND THEY
GOING TO DO IT IN TIME THERE MAY
BE OTHER CALLING TODAY THEY
WON'T BUT WHAT WE'RE TELLING
THEM IS.
IT'S TIME RIGHT AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL GIVE IT MORE PRIORITY.
IN THE PACKAGE THEN THAT'LL BE
MY CLOSER GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE CLERK.
QUIRK.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM -- SENATOR
MITCHELL THIS SHOULD BE --
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR HILL AYE.
AYE MORALE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL HI I HAS TO VOTE
HOLDING FOR THE AFTER MEMBERS
THANK YOU TO WORK ON IT
[inaudible]
SURE KALRA [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB [inaudible]
FIVE TWENTY WELCOME.
HOW DOES THIS COMMITTEE LOOK FOR
THE OTHER SIDE?
SHE'S LIKE A LETTER.
YEAH.
BUT VERY MUCH SHARON SENATORS --
PROBLEMS IN AB FIVE TWENTY THIS
DEFINES WHEN A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS
DE MINIMUS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
DETERMINING THE PREVAILING WAGE
APPLIES PRIVATE PROJECTS USING
PUBLIC FUNDS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE PROJECT IS
DE MINIMUS SO LONG AS IT IS LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND LESS THAN
2%.
OF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PROJECT IS NOT
SUBJECT THE PREVAILING WAGE Là
EVEN IF IT RECEIVES A PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES SUBSIDY.
IT THAT SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE PROJECT.
CHOOSE THE TERM DE MINIMUS IS
NOT DEFINED IN THE STATUTE THERE
IS NO GUIDANCE AS TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL PUBLIC SUBSIDY
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED DE
MINIMUS.
THIS IS LED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO MAKE INCONSISTENT
RULINGS AS TO WHAT IS DE MINIMUS
LEADING TO CONFUSION AND
LITIGATION ON WHAT THE TERM
ACTUALLY MEANS. FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
DEPARTMENT APPROVED AS DE
MINIMUS A ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PUBLIC SUBSIDY TO NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR NOT
PROCESSING FACILITY PROJECT.
SINCE IT WAS ONLY ONE POINT 75%.
OF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST BUT
THEN WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT ONE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
OF TAXPAYER MONEY -- CERTAINLY
IS SIGNIFICANT.
ABOUT A SUBSIDY FOR A PRIVATE
PROJECT IS MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
2% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT COST IS
A NOTABLE TAXPAYER INVESTMENT
AND IT IS REASONABLE. TO REQUIRE
PREVAILING WAGES AT THE
DEVELOPER WANTS A PUBLIC SUBSIDY
OVER THAT AMOUNT.
UNDER THIS BILL NO DEVELOPER IS
REQUIRED TO TAKE A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY OF THE DE MINIMUS AMOUNT
IF THEY DO NOT WANT TO PAY THE
PREVAILING WAGE.
OF HOLDING A PREVAILING WAGE
LAWS IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
ENSURE THAT CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
AWARDED PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTS
BY VIRTUE OF PAYING LOW WAGES.
AND UNDERCUTTING A COMPETITORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT AND
WILL.
TAKE IT OVER TO THE INCOMPARABLE
SAYS IDEAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
PRESSURE THAT I KNOW.
OF A LOT OF MEANING [inaudible]
THE TRUE.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS OF SOCIETY
AS A BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCILTHE PROUD SPONSORS OF
THIS LEGISLATION -- WE ARE --
DID COMPLETE AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT THEY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTION ABOUT THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL AND WHAT IT
ACTUALLY ACHIEVES OR SEEKS TO
ACHIEVE.
ON THE PREVAILING WAGE STATUTES
WERE ENACTED TO ENSURE THAT IT
WAS A READILY AND AVAILABLE
SKILLED.
WORKFORCE FOR THE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC PROJECTS THAT WERE
AVAILABLE BY THE BY THE STATE OR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE EXPANSION OF THE PREVAILING
WAGE AND THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
INCLUDED THE TERM TO MINIMIZE
BUT IT WAS NOT A FIGHT.
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS CHOSE 2% AS
THE NUMBER A PERCENTAGE OF THE
TOTAL PROJECT COST.
BUT AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED THOSE NUMBERS ARE
COMING IN VERY HIGH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TERMS OF PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES TO A PRIVATE DEVELOPER.
SO IT IS CONTRARY TO THE SPIRIT
OF THE PREVAILING WAGE LAW THAT
ONLY INSURERS THE WORKERS GET A
FAIR AND DECENT HEY.
BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES THE USE OF
APPRENTICES OF PROMISES THAT I
THINK A LOT OF US YOU HAVE
DEBATED HERE LEGISLATION TO TRY
TO ATTRACT MORE.
WHAT THAT DOES FOR ANY TYPE OF
DEVELOP OR CONTRACTOR IS IT
PROVIDES THE NEXT GENERATION OF
SKILLED WORKERS AND AS YOU KNOW
THERE HAS BEEN DISCUSSIONS OVER
THERE BEING A LETTER LABOR
SHORTAGE OF SKILLED WORKERS TO
ACHIEVE NOT ONLY?
PUBLIC WORKS IN THE FUTURE BUT
ALSO IN THE HOUSING RESIDENTIAL
MARKET -- WHICH WE BELIEVE FOR A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT REASONS
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE
BUT IT'S BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
WAGES HAVE NOT KEPT UP.
WITH INFLATION AND THE COST OF
LIVING AND SO IT MAKES IT LESS
ATTRACTIVE FOR WORKERS TO JUST.
CHAU ALSO THERE ISN'T AN
INHERENT.
SYSTEM WITHIN THE RESIDENTIAL
MARKET TO ACTUALLY TRAIN WORKERS
IN THAT RESPECT WE ARE NOT
CHANGING ANY TYPE OF A CURRENT
EXEMPTION AS IT EXISTS WITHIN
THE LABOR CODE AND THERE'S A
LITANY OF EXEMPTIONS FOR
RESIDENTIAL PROJECTS IN THE CODE.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THERE
SHOULD BE A MONETARY CAP ON THE
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC SUBSIDIES SO
THAT THE DEVELOPER CAN MAKE A
CHOICE WHETHER TO ACCEPT THAT
AND THEN TRIGGERED THE
PREVAILING WAGE OR TO ACCEPT UP
TO THE AMOUNT AND THEN DID?
NOT RECEIVE THE REST FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK.
GOVERNOR THE MORNING GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SCOTT GOVERNOR HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE LARGEST
ARTICLE BUILDERS IN THE STATE WE
ARE SIGNATORY TO THE CARPENTERS
AND LABORS UNION.
WE BUILD MOST OF THE LARGE
PUBLIC PROJECTS AND PRIVATE
PROJECTS IN THE STATE.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE NEED
CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET PLACE
YOU KNOW THERE HAS BEEN --
UNCERTAINTY IN THE PAST IN
LITIGATION OVER THE PAST OVER
PROJECTS WE'VE COMMENCED WHERE
THERE HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS IS IT
A PUBLIC OR IS IT NOT A PUBLIC.
IN THE END WE GO TO COURT AND
THAT UNCERTAINTY DOESN'T BENEFIT
OUR MEMBERS -- THIS PROVIDES THE
CERTAINTY WE NEED TO AVOID THOSE
PROBLEMS IT ALSO ADDRESSES
MISTER DE HAS RAISED THE SKILLED
LABOR SHORTAGE WE NEED.
WORKERS IN THE PIPELINE WE ARE
HAVING LABOR SHORTAGES
PARTICULARLY IN THE RESIDENTIAL
MARKET AND OUR MEMBERS BUILD A
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF ALL
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING MULTI
FAMILY IN THE STATE AS WELL.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO GOVERNOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS
WALKER ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SHEET METAL AIR CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS AND FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED ONE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLYN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BIGGER.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE MONICA
BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATEASSOCIATION LEXICAL WORKERS A
CALIFORNIA STATE I'VE TRADES
COUNCIL OF WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS.
IN THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT CRIMMINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE
HEARD IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT A
COMMITTEE GOTTEN OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME.
FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER SILVIO FOR OUR HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION -- JUST TO
START OFF -- WANNA MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE PERCENT THRESHOLD
THAT IS IN THE BILL -- WHEN
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED VERY
SIMILAR BILLS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN HE SAID THAT
THE 2% THRESHOLD WAS LONG
STANDING PRACTICE AND THEY'RE
NOT BEEN ANY INDICATIONS OF
PROBLEMS IN BOTH OF THOSE VETO
MESSAGES?
SO WE ARE NOT OPPOSED 22% OUR
CONCERN HAS TO DO WITH THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR TRIGGERING THRESHOLD.
IT IS GOING TO MAKE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE PARTNER
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON
EFFORTS TO GET GREEN BUILDING
TECHNOLOGIES ENERGY EFFICIENCY
TECHNOLOGIES ALL THOSE PUBLIC
POLICY GOALS.
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS INTO
THE MARKET PLACE.
WITH THIS BILL AS IT IS
CURRENTLY -- DRAFTED. FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE NOW CB I A HAS
BEEN REALLY ON THE FOREFRONT AND
THE LEADING EDGE OF GOING AFTER
GREEN ENERGY EFFICIENCY MEASURES --
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE STATE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO HAVE
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE TAILORED AND DESIGNED
TO THE UP FRONT START OF A LOT
OF THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES BRING
THE COST DOWN.
CASE IN POINT.
THE NEW SOLAR HOME PART.
GRAHAM THIS HAS BEEN THE STATE'S
PREMIER SOLAR INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
IN THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF ITS
LIFE IT TOOK SOLAR PENETRATION
ACROSS THE STATE FROM 1% 220% IN
THREE YEARS.
IF IT NOT FOR THAT PROGRAM.
OTHERS THE STATE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN IN A POSITION ONE YEAR AGO
TO ADOPT A STATEWIDE SOLAR
MANDATE.
AND NOW THAT THAT PROGRAM IS
BEGIN THE RAMP DOWN THE STATE IS
LOOKING AROUND GOING K. WHERE WE
GOING NEXT AND WE NOW KNOW IT'S
ELECTRIFICATION IS FULL
EXTRICATION IS EVEY CHARGING ITS
BATTERY STORAGE.
ELECTRIC WATER HEATING ELECTRIC
SPACE HEATING AND PROBABLY
TECHNOLOGIES AND PROGRAMS THAT
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT YET.
THAT WILL COME ALONG IN THE
FUTURE [inaudible]
YEAH.
PASSING THIS BILL IS GOING TO
IMPACT ALL OF THOSE EFFORTS WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
RISK.
THAT A THREE THOUSAND DOLLAR OR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
INCENTIVE ON EACH AND EVERY HOME.
IS GOING TO TRIGGER PREVAILING
WAGE AND RISE THE COST OF EACH
AND EVERY HOME BY EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS MINIMUM.
THERE'S MUCH HIGHER PRICES IN
CERTAIN REGIONS OF THE STATE.
SO FOR THAT WE HAVE OFFERED AN
AMENDMENT WE ARE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN WORK ON KATHLEEN NOT
RESIDENTIAL -- WE LOOK FOR TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION -- BUT
AS OF RIGHT NOW WE'RE VERY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
YOU DON'T HI CAM STONE ON IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS HAS LONG AND
CAPABILITY DETERMINED WHETHER I
PROJECTS AS SPENDING IS DE
MINIMUS OR NOT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING SO SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE AS GOVERNOR
BROWN NOTED IN -- HIS VETO
MESSAGE A VERY SIMILAR.
LEGISLATION HE SAID AND I QUOTE.
LONGSTANDING PRACTICE HAS BEEN
TO VIEW THE SUBSIDY IN CONTEXT
OF THE PROJECT.
WRESTLED FOR DETERMINATIONS
THERE HAS BEEN NO SHOWING THAT
THE CURRENT PRACTICES
UNREASONABLE WHILE I REMAIN A
STAUNCH SUPPORTER OF PREVAILING
WAGES I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS
MEASURE IS TOO RESTRICTIVE AND
MAY HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
WE AGREE ON RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU STONE.
THEN I BECOME AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
BUT OUR OP [inaudible] TO
MINIMIZE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU HOW WOULD
YOU RESPOND.
TO THE CBA'S CONCERNS SUCH.
DIFFICULT ON THE SOLAR.
SURE [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY -- YOU KNOW.
A COUPLE THINGS AND AND THAT
PROGRAM THAT WAS REFERRED BEEN
TAKING APPLICATIONS FROM
DEVELOPERS.
BUT BUT MORE SIGNIFICANTLY.
I WOULD JUST SAY THIS.
I'M AS WE DO RAMP UP AS A STATE
A GREEN BUILDING OUR GREEN
ENERGY -- BUILDING IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE UNDERSTAND --
WHAT KIND OF?
FUTURE WE WANT FOR OUR STATE.
AND YOU KNOW AS WE RAMP BUT WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A
SKILLED TRAINED WORK FORCE.
THE THAT WE CAN RELY ON DURING
THIS TRANSITION WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT WE DON'T WILL HAVE A WORK
FORCE THAT IS RELYING ON LOW
WAGES OR A DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY --
THAT IS PARTNERING WITH THE
STATE ON GREEN BUILDING BY
RELYING ON LOW WAGES.
THERE'S A REASON WHY I IS OFTEN
TIMES YOU KNOW THOSE OF US AND I
KNOW THAT.
MANY THE SENATORS HERE CERTAINLY
BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT ON THE IN
IT IN TERMS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS.
AND IS ALSO.
AND AND YOU'VE ALSO BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT IN TERMS OF PROTECTING
WORKERS.
YOU CAN DO BOTH.
AND THERE'S AN UNDERSTAND.
CONCERN FROM THE BUILDING TRADES
AND OTHERS IN LABOR.
WENT AWAY ME TALK ABOUT PHASING
OUT FOSSIL FUEL JOBS WE TALK
ABOUT THESE GOOD HIGH PAYING
HIGH WAGE SKILLED JOBS THAT
WRITTEN A PHASE OUT ARE WE GOING
TO PHASE THEM OUT FOR A LOW END.
MINIMUM WAGE JOBS.
ADDITION TO THE GREEN ECONOMY
ARE WE GOING TO CREATE A GREEN
ECONOMY THAT TRULY BUILDS UPON
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN.
WHAT WE HAVE DONE AS A STATE IN
TERMS OF BUILDING A OF AN?
UNPARALLELED BUILDING TRADES AND
SKILLED WORK FORCE WE WANT THAT
TO CONTINUE IF WE TRULY WANT TO
SEE TRANSITION FROM FOSSIL FUELS
TO THE GREEN ECONOMY WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE SON CON ME THAT WORKS
FOR EVERYONE.
AND SO I DON'T BUY THE ARGUMENT
THAT WE CAN'T DO IT.
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE AND
WE OBVIOUSLY CAN'T DO IT AND NO
ONE IS FORCING A DEVELOPER TO
TAKE A SUBSIDY THIS IS TAXPAYER
MONEY.
WE HAVE WE'RE GONNA USE TAXPAYER
MONEY TO TRANSITION INTO THE
GREEN ECONOMY WE HAVE TO WE
CANNOT DO IT ON THE BACKS OF
WORKERS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
IT BY CREATING A WORKFORCE THAT
SKILLED AND THAT AS LIVING WAGES
AND CAN FURTHER.
BUILD UPON OUR CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- NOW TAKE THAT IS A
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
OF YES SORRY.
SENATE OVER -- DEVICE HERE.
THANK YOU SIR.
IS IT YOUR INTENT THAT THIS BILL
WILL ARM.
ALSO APPLY TO RESIDENTIAL
PROJECTS.
IT APPLIES TO RESIDENTIAL THAT
IS NOT EXEMPTED AND THERE'S
PLENTY OF EXEMPTS INCLUDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT ONE THAT I
KNOW.
THAT -- MANY IN THIS BUILDING
RIGHT BILLY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT --
A DISINCENTIVE ISING SO IT I
HEARD THERE ARE A NUMBER.
OF EXEMPTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST UNDERLAY BECAUSE SEVENTEEN
TWENTY INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
FACTORS AS WELL.
BUT IN GENERAL IF THE SUBSIDY IS
COMING FROM A GOVERNMENT ENTITY
IT WOULD APPLY TO ALL
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
RESIDENTIAL WITH THE EXEMPTIONS
THAT EXIST ABOUT NOW YOUR
OPPONENTS SUGGEST HAVE SOME
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WOULD YOU
BE WILLING TO TAKE.
WELL I'M WILLING TO LISTEN TO
ANYONE THAT HAS SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AS MALE TAKE THEM
ABOUT THEIR WORLD WERE HARD MY
DOOR IS AND CONTINUE TO BE OPEN.
TO OFFERS OF SUGGESTIONS AND SO
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM --
IF THERE'S A MEETING OF THE
MINDS CERTAINLY.
BUT THOUGH THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE POSITION THAT SOMEHOW
WE CAN'T.
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE GREEN
ECONOMY IN THESE GREEN ENERGY.
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE THIS IN THIS
AMOUNT I THINK IS A FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT AS TO THAT.
YEAH I HAVE USED TO BE --
INVOLVED WITH THE BILLING AND
REAL ESTATE SO WHAT WORRIES
BECAUSE SOME.
YOU KNOW I HAVE.
CHILDREN THAT ARE YOUNG AND THAT
FIRST TIME HOME BUYER MARKET ONE
OF THE MAIN DEMOGRAPHICS LEAVING
CALIFORNIA ARE ACCORDING TO WHO
WE ARE.
HOOVER INSTITUTE -- HOW MONEY
WALKS BUT THEY RECOMMENDED TO ME
YES -- YOUR HIGHLY EDUCATED
YOUNG PROFESSIONALS BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY NINE ONE OF
THE REASONS IS HOUSING.
AND SO WITH EVERYBODY'S TELLING
US WERE IN A HOUSING CRISIS AND
SO ALL THE STUFF GOING TO RAISE
THE COST A HOUSING -- WHICH IT
HAS BEEN AND SO THOSE THINGS YOU
KNOW WORRY ME AND THAT'S WHY
THIS IS CONCERNING ME.
COULD COULD COULD YOU EXPLAIN IF
SIR.
I MEANT SPECIFICALLY TARGETS ON
CLEAR ON THAT YEAH HAPPY TO I I
THINK I'D SAY TWO THINGS THE
EXEMPTION THAT'S BEEN REFERENCED --
IT IS IN THE CODE IT IS C. ONE
IT IS REFERRED TO MOST COMMONLY
AS DE MINIMUS EXEMPTION.
WITHIN THAT EXEMPTION THERE IS
AN EXCEPTION.
WITH.
WITH AGREEMENTS WITH STATE
AGENCIES.
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
GRAMS HI THAT THE STATE IS
PROMULGATING THROUGH.
IS THE C. E. C. THE CPUC OR
OTHER SO THERE'S AN EXIT AN
EXCEPTION TO THE EXEMPTION.
IN THE CODE THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A
PROBLEM.
SO THE AMENDMENT THAT WE PUT OUT
THERE WAS TO ACTUALLY SAY THE
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT SHALL NOT
APPLY TO RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION.
IT WAS NOT TO GET OURSELVES OUT
OF THE 2%.
IT WAS TO SAY WE CAN WE CAN
ABIDE BY THAT WE THINK IT CAN
WORK BUT THE TO INNER CITY FIVE
IS GOING TO MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO PLAY WITH
THIS BILL.
IN THE TERMINOLOGY USED
DIFFICULT.
WHAT IS THAT SPECIFIC WENT MEAN
I I WOULD ASSUME THAT MEANS
HIGHER COSTS PASSED ON? TO THE
POTETIAL HOMEOWNERS THAT'S
RIGHT I MEAN.
AGAIN SO YOU FOR OUR CIA.
A WE HAVE LOTS OF NUMBERS THAT
SHOW THAT COST DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN -- PREVAILING WAGE IN ON
TWENTY FOURTEEN I CITED EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
NUMBER COMES FROM A TWENTY
FOURTEEN STUDY OF A TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT HOUSE THE
PRICE DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN WAS
OUT.
JUST OVER THIRTY THREE DOLLARS
THAT WAS.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS MEMBERS OF CB
I BROUGHT THEIR NUMBERS -- IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
ESPECIALLY IS THERE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS.
ON IN OTHER AREAS OF OF LABOR
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER -- THERE HAVE BEEN
BOOKS.
AND INFORMATION HAS BEEN SHARED
THAT IS SHOWING THAT THAT NUMBER
IS. FIFTY DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARSA SQUARE FOOT SO WE TIME
ISN'T.
VERY LARGE NUMBERS AND THOSE
NUMBERS.
WILL.
MAKE THE BUILDER SO RISK ADVERSE
THAT.
THEY WILL NOT BE MOVING FORWARD
ANY THESE EFFORTS ON GREEN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY OR WHATEVER
THEY ARE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THOUGH.
WE DO -- YES.
THANK US SHARE I WOULD JUST SAY
YOU KNOW WE CAN CERTAINLY HAVE A
CONTINUE DEBATE ON THE NUMBERS
BUT ALSO BE TO PAY FOR THAT
DIFFERENTIAL ONE OR THE OTHER.
BY CREATING A LOW WAGE WORKFORCE
THAT CAN AFFORD HOUSING SO I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING IN SILICON
VALLEY THIS OFFER ENGINEERING
YOUNG FAMILY TWENTY FOUR TO LIVE --
IN SILICON VALLEY ALMOST
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE INSTALLING
SOLAR DOES A STYLE INSTALLING
THIS PRODUCT BUILDING THE HOMES.
I CAN'T EVEN AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THE BAY AREA AND THEY HAVE TO
TRAVEL FOR THREE HOURS AND HOURS.
OF WORK TWELVE HOUR SHIFTS JUST
TO HEAD BACK HOME IN THEIR HOME
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WE CAN DO BETTER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AND ALL
WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA CARE KALRA.
IS THERE MOTIONS THAT BEGAN.
ALMOST THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM.
THE THE SENATOR MITCHELL DUE TO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THE SO CALLED.
SENATOR HILL HI BILL I RURAL.
RURAL NO JACKSON.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE.
THE WHOLE THE ROLE OF THE PRESS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I SEE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I THINK -- OF SURE ONE SECOND WE
DO HAVE ONE OF THE BILL LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
MOVIE TO I AM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE PRETTY.
THANK YOU ARE CHEN SANDERS PART
OF HIS ON A COMMITTEE BILL AB --
EIGHTEEN FOR THAT WE INTRODUCED
AT THE REQUEST OF CARILLO SHUT
TO UPDATE THE REPORTING METHODS
FOR WORK RELATED DEATHS OR
SERIOUS INJURY INJURIES TO CAL
OSHA.
THE BILL ABOUT EMPLOYERS REPORT
THE SERIES INSTANCE TO AN ONLINE
MECHANISM AND STARTED EMAIL
WHILE RETAINING THE OPTION TO
REPORT BY TELEPHONE WE'RE ALSO
TAKING A CLARIFYING AMENDMENT
THAT THE ONLINE MECHANISM.
IS NOT IN PLACE WHEN THE BILL
BECOMES EFFECTIVE EMPLOYERS
CONSOLE PORT THROUGH EMAIL UNTIL
IT IS -- THIS THIS UPDATE IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE EMPLOYERS
REPORT AN INJURY OR FATALITY BY
EMAIL CAN WE GO BACK TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
WORKPLACE INCIDENT.
WHEN CAL OSHA RECEIVES
INCOMPLETE INFORMATION ITS
ABILITY TO PROMPTLY INITIATE AN
INVESTIGATION OR TAKE ANY OTHER
ACTION IS SIMPLY CURTAILED AND
THIS IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO PACK
THE?
THE SAFETY RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
MUCH DARKER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE WE JUST ADD
TO THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS THAT
THE MAKING A CLARIFICATION TO
THE SECTION OF LAW IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT A CALLOUS TO
FIND OUT ABOUT THESE KIND OF
INCIDENTS RIGHT AWAY IF THAT A
DIFFERENCE OF TWENTY FOUR HOURS
OR FORTY EIGHT HOURS CAN MAKE
ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN FINDING
OUT.
WHAT HAPPENED WHETHER OR NOT
THEY NEED TO GO OUT AND DO AN
IMMEDIATE INSPECTION TO MAKE
SURE THAT SOMETHING THAT BY
DEFINITION BECAUSE A VERY
SERIOUS INCIDENT IF NOT A
FATALITY IS TAKEN CARE OF IN A
TIMELY FASHION -- I VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN AND I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON LOOK AT THE ARE FOR
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE DON'T ELIMINATE THE ONLINE
YES OPPORTUNITIES BEFORE THE NEW
REGULATIONS REPLACE.
THANK YOU THAT UP AND COME TO
THE COMMITTEE CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
QUESTION SIR.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE OR
ELSE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible] FIFTEEN
COMMITTEE BILL [inaudible]
PAN I FOR HOPE FOR VIRTUAL THE
ROLE FOR AFTER MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CARE KALRA THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ARAMBULA WELCOME.
THANK MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB.
TWELVE TWENTY THREE I AM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB.
TWELVE TWENTY THREE REGARDING
LIVING ORGAN DONATIONS.
NEARLY SIXTY NINE HUNDRED LIVING
DONOR TRANSPLANTS WERE PERFORMED
LAST YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES.
INCLUDING SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO HERE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR MANY
PATIENTS AN ORGAN FAILURE AN
ORGAN TRANSPLANT CAN BE THEIR
ONLY REMAINING MEDICAL OPTION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW LIVING ORGAN
DONORS ARE ALLOWED UP TO THIRTY
DAYS OF PAID LEAVE AFTER SURGERY
TO FULLY RECOVER.
JOHN HOPKINS MEDICINE REPORTS
THAT FULL RECOVERY FROM ORGAN
DONATION.
TAKES AN ADDITIONAL FOUR TO SIX
WEEKS WITH SOME PATIENTS NEEDING
EVEN MORE TIME.
LIVING DONORS ALSO EXPERIENCED
DISCRIMINATION WITH SOME
INSURERS AND DO NOT HAVE
EXPLICIT JOB.
WELL THEY RECOVER FROM ORGAN
DONATION SURGERY. FOR EXAMPLE A
STUDY AT THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF HEALTH DEMONSTRATED THAT A
HIGH PROPORTION OF KIDNEY DONORS.
HAD DIFFICULTY CHANGING.
OR INITIATING INSURANCE PLANS
AND IT WAS PARTY FIRST
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT WITH LIFE
INSURANCE.
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE SIX TO
ADDRESS THESE HURDLES. FOR ORGAN
DONATION WITH A TWO PRONGED
APPROACH.
FIRST AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WOULD ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE TO TAKE
AN ADDITIONAL ON PAID LEAVE OF
UP TO THIRTY BUSINESS DAYS.
IN A ONE YEAR PERIOD FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ORGAN DONATION.
THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT AN
EMPLOYEE FIRST MUST EXHAUST ALL
AVAILABLE SICK LEAVE.
BEFORE TAKING THIS ON PAID LEAVE.
BY ADDING THIS OPTION FOR
ADDITIONAL ON PAID LEAVE IF
NEEDED.
POTENTIAL ORGAN DONORS WILL HELP
COMFORT KNOWING THAT THEY CAN
TAKE THE NECESSARY TIME FOR A
FULL RECOVERY WITHOUT FEAR OF
LOSING THEIR JOBS.
SECOND AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT INSURERS.
FROM DECLINING.
READING OR LIMITING COVERAGE OF
A PERSON UNDER A LIFE OR
DISABILITY INSURANCE POLICY.
SOLELY DUE.
TO STATUS OF THE PERSON ASA
LIVING ORGAN DONOR.
THESE TWO APPROACHES IN TO
REDUCE THE HURDLES FOR ORGAN
DONATION.
BY INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
SURGICAL RECOVERY TIME BY THIRTY
DAYS.
OF UNPAID LEAVE AND PROHIBITING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ORGAN
DONORS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SCOTT SADLER WITH THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN HEALTH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AB TWO OF TWENTY
THREE THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
INSURANCE DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON A PERSON'S STATUS AS AN ORGAN
DONOR AND ONE SURE JOB ACCESS
JOB.
PROTECTED LEAVE FOR AN ORGAN
DONATION.
I REPRESENT THE AMERICAN CAN BE
FUN A K. F. AS A NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT THE FOR
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS IS HELP
PEOPLE FIGHT KIDNEY DISEASE AND
LIVE HEALTHIER LIVES.
WE RUN THE STE THE NATION'S
LARGEST FREE KIDNEY HEALTH
SCREENING PROGRAM I WORK EVERY
DAY TO HELP PEOPLE PREVENT
KIDNEY DISEASE AND DETECTED AS
EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
KIDNEY TRANSPLANT AXES A LITERAL
LIFELINE FOR PATIENTS SUFFERING.
FROM KIDNEY FAILURE.
OFFERING THE CHANCE FOR A LONGER
HEALTHIER LIFE.
BUT THE SEVERE SHORTAGE OF AVAIL
AVAILABLE ORGANS IN THE UNITED
STATES MEANS THE MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
ARE WE THE DONATION.
AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE WILL
REMOVE THE BARRIERS FOR LIVING
DONOR.
LIVING ORGAN DONATIONS.
WE BELIEVE THE GUARANTEEING JOB
SECURITY WHEN THEY TAKE TIME OFF
TO RECOVER FROM ORGAN DONATION
SURGERY.
AND PROHIBITING INSURANCE
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ORGAN
DONORS ARE NOT ONLY SENSIBLE
PROTECTIONS BUT ALSO GOOD POLICY.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ENCOURAGE
DRIVE A GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS MEDICINE BY ON
BEHALF OF DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THE NO ONE IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM -- SENATOR
PAN -- WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
YOU KNOW ONE ON PERSONAL LEVEL
WE RECOGNIZED OUR NONPROFIT OF
THIS YEAR THIS YEAR WHICH WAS
YOUTH LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE IN
THEIR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SISTER.
DONATED HER KIDNEY TO A FAMILY
MEMBER.
AND HER DIFFICULTY.
GETTING BACK TO WORK IT WAS A
MAJOR MOTIVATION FOR US WORKING
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
JUST WANTED TO THANK THOSE IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHO HELPED TO GIVE
US VOICE AND IDEAS OR WHAT WE DO
A TERRORIST. TO THE TO THE TO A
WONDERFUL. ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
THE QUESTIONS I HAD WAS HAS
THERE BEEN.
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE CURRENT
THIRTY DAY REQUIREMENT --
ALLOWANCE AND HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
WITH THAT AND I THINK YOU'VE
ANSWERED THAT.
I JUST ANECDOTALLY ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE -- SOME WOMEN
HE FLOORS FATHER DONATED A
KIDNEY TO ONE OF HIS FRIENDS --
AND I KNOW THAT -- MISTER SENIOR
MISTER FLORA OF TOOK ABOUT. NINE
WEEKS TO GET BACK ON THE TRACTOR
DOWN ASCALON SO DEPENDING ON
YOUR JOB IT CAN TAKE A LOT
LONGER TO GET BACK TO FULL
STATUS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
HAVE A MOTOR FROM A TENER PAN
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS TO PASS TO INSURANCE
COMMITTEE SENATOR HELD BY BILL I
MORRELL [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE PAN. FOUR VOTES
WILL HOLD ROLL OVER FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO I SEE YOU
THERE YOU ARE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NICE TO SEE WE ARE MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B. FIVE
NINETY THREE AND THEN WE WILL GO.
TO ITEM FOURTEEN AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AFTER THAT
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
WHEN THE RED AREA?
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT A.
B..
FIVE NINETY THREE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
RUNNING CORNY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
FEDERAL WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT.
LOCAL BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA TOO
VITAL WORK PROVIDING JOB
TRAINING AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND ARE DISTRICTS.
IN LA COUNTY THE LA COUNTY
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
ALONE PLACE OVER ONE THOUSAND
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
IN. TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LOCAL
WORKFORCE SPORTS ARE MANDATED TO
TRACK THE RETENTION RATES WAGES
AND THE TYPE OF INDUSTRIES ARE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS PARTICIPATE.
PARTICIPANTS EARN AND WORK IN
THEY DO THIS THROUGH THE BIG
BASS WAIT FILE SECURE
INFORMATION THAT IS.
HOUSED IN THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE EDT.
OUR ONLINE SYSTEM CALLED CAL
JOBS.
HOWEVER EDITH ABILITY TO SHARE
THIS INFORMATION WITH LOCAL
BOARD THIS LIMITED BY THE
CURRENT WORDING OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS YOU I SEE.
SINCE ALL PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS
ARE ALREADY ENTERED INTO CAL
JOBS ET DE ALREADY COLLECTS THE
DATA FOR NON FEDERALLY FUNDED
PARTICIPANTS.
BUT LACKED THE EXPLICIT.
THAT MISSION TO SHARE THE DATA
BACK WITH THE LOCAL BOARD AB
FIVE NINE THREE MAKES CHANGES.
TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CODE THAT ALLOWS LOCAL BOARDS
AND CITY COUNTY DEPARTMENTS OR
AGENCIES THAT ADMINISTER PUBLIC
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
TO ACT THIS QUARTERLY WAGE DATA
IN ORDER TO EVALUATE RESEARCH OR
FORECAST THE EFFECTIVENESS.
OF PUBLIC WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER.
THE ANALYSIS -- RECOMMENDS THAT
WE ADDRESS CONCERNS RACING
REGARDING CONFIDENTIALITY.
I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH OUR SPONSORS
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
THE D. E. AND THE D. EDT. TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS THANK YOU
OF COURSE WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IS ERIK FLORES WHO IS A
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU WE RECEIVED A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- WE
REPRESENT THE FORTY FIVE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS OVER A HUNDRED OTHER.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SYSTEM
INCLUDING K. -- TWELVE DISTRICTS
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS
FEDERAL INVESTMENT IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS FALLEN BY OVER
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THAT'S OVER.
PRODUCTION I THIS DECLINE HAS
LED TO A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS BACK
FILLING THOSE OF FUNDS WITH
ADDITIONAL STATE AND LOCAL
DOLLARS AS WELL AS PHILANTHROPIC.
SOME OF OUR BOARD SEE AS LITTLE
AS 13% OF THEIR FUNDS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL WORKFORCE
INNOVATION AND OPPORTUNITIES ACT.
THIS LEADS TO THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE IN QUESTION THE
CALIFORNIA CODE DOES NOT
CURRENTLY EXPRESSLY PERMIT LOCAL
WORKFORCE AREAS ACCESS TO THAT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DATA.
IF IT IS NOT PAID FOR BY FEDERAL
DOLLARS -- WITH THESE DISPARATE
FUNDING STREAMS IT MEANS THAT
THE STATE IS ONLY GATHERED
THROUGH THE ACTUAL LAKE WORK OF
CASE MANAGEMENT CHECKUPS AEGEE
PHONE CALLS.
EMAILS FOR OP PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS TO BE ABLE TO
REPORT ON HOW THOSE PROGRAMS AND
PLACEMENTS ARE DOING.
AB FIVE NINETY WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
AREA TO REQUEST THAT BASE WHICH
FILE FROM ET DE WITH THE RESPECT
TO WITH RESPECT TO THE RESULTS
OF STATE LOCAL OR PHILANTHROPIC
THE FUNDED PROGRAMS.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US OUR BOARDS
TO USE THOSE OF FUNDS FAR MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND MORE MOVE THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT
DELAY WORKFORCE PROGRAMS BEING
EVALUATED.
WE WORKED AND RECORDED ON OUT
WITH RESPECT TO WORKING WITH EDT
WE HAVE HAD -- THEM IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS FROM THE BEGINNING
OF THE BILL AND IT TO WORKING
WITH THEM TO ADDRESS THOSE
PRIVACY CONCERNS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE STATE OF
NEW YORK PASSED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWED THEIR
LOCAL WORK FORCE AREAS TO
REQUEST THIS YOU Y. DATA THROUGH
A MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE NEW YORK DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR.
WE'RE WORKING WITH EDT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT SUCCESSFUL
LEGISLATION THAT IS IN PRACTICE
TODAY AND THAT STATE CAN
POTENTIALLY BE REPLICATED AND
MATCHED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE SERVED
OVER A ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CUSTOMERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONE IN. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR THEM IN THE
ON OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES THAT.
HAVE STE BEEN SERVED THROUGH THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM AND
CALIFORNIA'S.
OUT.
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
LET ME ANSWER THE TESTIMONY
APPRECIATED OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING -- WE HAVE THE CITY
AND COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO THAT
SHARING WITH THE LOCALS PART
THAT'S ACTUALLY CRITICAL IT'S
GONNA GET A LOT MORE PEOPLE
EMPLOYED DOWN THE ROAD OR DRIVE
A COMPUTER.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
WE HEAR BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
FOR HAVE.
OF THE FOUR ENTERTAIN THE RIGHT
I DO APPRECIATE THE THE CON THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION ON THE
CONFIDENTIALITY I THINK THAT'S
THE MAYBE A CRITICAL PIECE THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS IS.
IS -- MONITORED AND CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT NEW YORK AND THAT MAY
BE THE SOLUTION THAT CAN WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM.
SENATOR MITCHELL -- THIS IS TO
PASS -- TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
HILL BY HILL AYE MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
I PAN. FIVE FOUR VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OVER FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN EIGHT SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU SEE YOU LATER.
I WOULD SAY THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
CERTAINLY LEAD AHEAD OF NEW YORK
SOMETIMES.
ALL THE TIME IT ALL THE TIME.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT CREDITS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING -- THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
PROBABLY YOU -- HERE TO PRESENT
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE WORKERS ARE
PAID FAIRLY FOR THEIR WORK BY
PROVIDING CLARITY.
WHEN THE PREVAILING WAGES
REQUIRED ON PRE CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES CURRENTLY THERE IS?
GEN BETWEEN AGENCIES CONTRACTORS
AND LABOR GROUPS AROUND WHEN AND
WHERE PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY ON PRE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES.
STATE LAW MAKE THE CLEAR THE PRE
CONSTRUCTION PHASES OF A PROJECT
FALL UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC WORKS.
ND THAT'S REQUIRE THE PAYMENT
OF PREVAILING WAGE HOWEVER THE
AMBIGUITY AROUND THE DEFINITION
OF PRE CONSTRUCTION HAS LED TO
CONFUSION AMONG STAKEHOLDERS.
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AS
TO WHEN PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY FIGHT
ASSESSMENTS FEASIBILITY STUDIES
ARE CRUCIAL TO CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND THEY TYPICALLY THE
TERM AND THE SUITABILITY OF THE
LAND WATER WHERE PROJECT IS.
TO BE POTENTIALLY BILLS SIMPLY
PUT UP A PROJECT WITH TYPICALLY
NOT MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT THE
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF THIS
ASSESSMENT OF THE LAND.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY WILL CLARIFY
THAT PRE CONSTRUCTION ALSO
RELATES TO PUBLIC WORKS.
PROJECTS ALSO INCLUDE SITE
ASSESSMENTS AND FEASIBILITY
STUDIES TO ENSURE WORKERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY ARE
RECEIVING THE PREVAILING WAGE
THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED.
TO FURTHER AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WILL SPECIFY THAT SITE
ASSESSMENTS OF VISIBILITY
STUDIES FALL UNDER THE
DEFINITION OF PRE CONSTRUCTION
REGARDLESS.
OF WHETHER FURTHER CONSTRUCTION
IS PERFORM AFTER THE ASSESSMENT
IS COMPLETED HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TEMPERAMENTS POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE INTERNATIONAL.
OPERATING ENGINEERS.
THANK YOU MARTY A GOOD MORNING
UP AS STATED -- WE BELIEVE THIS
PLACE APPLIES CLARITY AWARDING
AGENCIES -- CONTRACTORS ACTING
AS BIDDERS AND ALSO FOR CEMENT
ENTITIES FOR THE NO UP FRONT
GOING AND THE PREVAILING WAGES
IS REQUIRED AND USE OF
APPRENTICES ARE REQUIRED.
BUT WHAT IT DOES NOT APPLY TO
WE'VE WE'VE HAD SOME INQUIRIES
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO A GEOLOGIST
OR AN ARCHITECT THIS IS THE ONLY
TRADITIONAL.
WORK MAN PART OF IT A
TRADITIONAL BUILDING TRADE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT
THAT WOULD BE PERFORMING WORK ON
THESE PRE CONSTRUCTION SERVICES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU OF A BIG THE QUESTION
I HAD WAS THAT I I KNEW THAT WAS
A CONCERN ARCHITECTS AND
ENGINEERS REYES THOSE THOSE
ISSUES AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THERE WILL BE
CLARIFICATION I DON'T THINK THE
BILL STATES AT THIS POINT -- BY
I WOULD SAY MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
CURRENTLY NO DEPARTMENT US
RELATIONS DOES NOT -- ISSUE WAY
SHE TERMINATION FOR OUR TECHS
ARE GEOLOGISTS THIS IS ONLY FOR
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE WAY TOO
TERMINATION IS ISSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL ENGINES.
WOULD NOT APPLY WOULD NOT APPLY.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE CHAIR. FOR
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU --
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
READ IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
YES THANK YOU SEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU I KNOW SOME ISSUES
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN A STATED
THEY DO NOT FLY -- THIS ASSEMBLY --
TO ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE PAID
THE PREVAILING WAGE TEMPERATE
CONSTRUCTION SITES AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR ABOUT.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM A SENATOR PAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HELD BY
HILL AYE MORRELL.
WELL NO JACKSON.
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE PAN.
PAN.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OVER FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT
SIMILAR MAIENSCHEIN.
WELCOME.
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM NUMBER TEN
A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WELCOME
AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
PROTECT PROTECT WORKERS
CALIFORNIA'S EPIDEMIC OF DEADLY
WILDFIRES.
CONTINUES TO WORSEN THE COMPLEX
MIXTURE OF CHEMICALS AND
SUBSTANCES FOUND IN WILD FIRES.
CAN PENETRATE DEEP INTO THE
LUNGS AND CAUSE SERIOUS HEALTH
PROBLEMS MILLIONS OF CUT INS
WORK OUTDOORS AND RISK EXPOSURE
TO THIS HAZARD.
WELL REGULATIONS EXIST TO
PROTECT WORKERS FROM GENERAL
HAZARDS AN AIRBORNE EXPOSURES
THESE REGULATIONS DO NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS.
THE UNIQUELY UNPREDICTABLE
NATURE OF WILDFIRE SMOKE AB
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE
OSHA -- TO ADOPT THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO
MAKE RESPIRATORS AVAILABLE TO
OUTDOOR WORKERS ON ANY DAY THOSE
WORKERS COULD REASONABLY BE
EXPECTED TO BE EXPOSED TO
HARMFUL LEVELS.
OF WILD FIRE SMOKE HERE WITH ME
TO TEST RIDE SUPPORTERS
MISDIAGNOSIS THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FED FEDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES WORK SAFE AND
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION -- TO
BASICALLY IS SOLVE THE ISSUE
THAT WE SAW HAPPEN A LOT LAST
YEAR DURING THE WORST OF THE
FIRES WHERE.
WHEN THE AIR WAS EXTREMELY BAD
IN MANY AREAS AROUND THE STATE
WE WENT AROUND AND SAW THAT LOTS
OF WORKERS WERE ESSENTIALLY
FORCED TO WORK OUTSIDE IN THIS
AIR?
WITH NO PROTECTION OF ANY KIND
AND THERE WASN'T MUCH
INFORMATION AVAILABLE AS TO WHAT
THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION WAS
WHAT KIND OF MASK TO WEAR
WHETHER OR NOT TO WEAR A MASK
WHETHER WAS REQUIRED.
SO IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT INTO
THE REGULATIONS AND FOUND THAT
THEY KIND OF RANGE FROM SO VEGAS
TO BE ALMOST USED. TO SO
CUMBERSOME THAT EVERYONE IS JUST
KIND OF IGNORING THEM AND SO WE
PETITION THE CALLUSES STANDARDS
BOARD TO PROMULGATE SOME NEW
REGULATIONS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND THAT PROCESS IS
HAPPENING THERE'S BEEN AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN
ONE HEARING.
AND A FINAL VOTE IS TENTATIVELY
SCHEDULED FOR JULY EIGHTEENTH
BUT THE BILL IS STILL NECESSARY
TO BASICALLY KEEP THE PRESSURE
ON THAT PROCESS.
AS WE HEARD DURING THE TESTIMONY
OF A QUIRK BILL THE WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY RULE MAKING
PROCESS HAS A TENDENCY.
TO DRAG ON FOR YEARS SEVERAL
YEARS IF NOT LONGER AND OVER A
SPAN OF TIME THAT LONG GIVEN THE
SEVERITY AND FREQUENCY THE FIRES
WERE LOOKING AT NOW THERE WILL
BE WHO KNOWS HOW MANY OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL YEARS SO.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
SOMETHING HAPPENS IN TIME FOR
THE BOOK OF THIS YEAR'S FIRE
SEASON.
IN ADDITION TO ADDRESSING THE
SPECIFIC WEAKNESSES WITH THE
RAGS THAT ARE THERE PARTICULARLY
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S CLEAR FOR
EMPLOYERS WHEN THEY DO HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING THAT.
RIGHT NOW IT'S KIND OF THE
SUBJECTIVE WHENEVER YOU THINK AN
EXPOSURE IS HARMFUL AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SWITCH THAT OVER TO A
MORE CLEAR STANDARD OF WHEN THE
AIR QUALITY INDEX REACHES A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD.
AND THEN ALSO TO DEAL WITH THE
CUMBERSOME NATURE OF SOME OF THE
REGULATIONS WHERE THEY'RE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO DO A
MEDICAL EVALUATION AND FIT
TESTING.
OF EVERY SINGLE WORKER BEFORE
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO WEAR ONE OF
THE AN NINETY FIVE MASKS WHICH
IS A REALLY FEASIBLE IF YOU'RE.
A COUPLE HUNDRED OUTDOOR WORKERS
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN A FIRE
STARTS AND YOU'VE GOT TO BRING A
PHYSICIAN AND TO PERSONALLY
EXAMINE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
IN THE SPAN OF A FEW HOURS IT'S
JUST NOT.
SOMETHING THAT WE THINK IS VERY
REALISTIC THE PALM BUT THE WAY
MOST OF THESE FIRES HAPPENED SO --
THOSE ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED IN
THE LANGUAGE BUT WE DO THINK THE
BILL IS STILL NECESSARY THERE IS
DEFINITELY -- THERE ARE SOME
VOICES IN THE PROCESS THAT ARE
TRYING TO SLOW IT DOWN THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO THE NATURE OF
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS AND SO THE
BILL IS STILL VERY MUCH DOING
WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO DO AND
HELPING KEEP THE PROCESS WORKING
THE WAY THAT -- THAT WE THINK IT
NEEDS TO TO WORK BEST FOR
WORKERS WE ARE TONIGHT.
GOOD THANK YOU -- YES THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE A GREAT MANY
OF OUR WORKERS WORK OUTSIDE AND
SO ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE SOME
RESPIRATORY PROTECTION.
ARE DURING THE WILDFIRE SEASON
WE THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT
THANKFULLY A GREAT MANY OF THE
UNITED CAN CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE.
DO YOU OFTEN SHUT DOWN WORK OF
BUT NOT ALL OF THEM AND
CERTAINLY IN THE NON UNION
CONSTRUCTION SECTOR THAT'S NOT
THE CASE.
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED THE
STANDARDS BOARD STAFF AS IN THE
DIVISION STAFF HAS WORKED SO
HARD TO GET THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS.
ON ROUND THE CUSP OF BEING
FINISHED BUT HAVING THIS BILL
OUT THERE KEEP THE PRESSURE ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY KNOW THAT
YOU ARE WATCHING.
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
THINK IS -- A VERY IMPORTANT TO
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD FOR THAT
REASON SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE BUILDING TRADES
AND HAPPY TO BE ON STRONG
SUPPORTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MORNING CHRIS CON
REPRESENTS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER KHAN.
A DRY RIVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION AT THE PORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NO ONE EXCELLENT BILL
THANK YOU LEADERSHIP IN THIS IN
THE IN KEEPING UP THE PRESSURE
ON PUSHING THE FEAR GET SENATOR
WRAP HIM.
IT IS A QUESTION ABOUT -- AND
AND THE EMERGENCY NATURE SEE OF
A TEMPORARY EXEMPTION FROM --
FIT TESTING FOR RESPIRATORS AND
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS IS THAT.
IF A RESPIRATOR DOESN'T FIT
APPROPRIATELY IT REALLY ISN'T
SERVING ITS FUNCTIONS SO -- SO I
GET THE IDEA THAT OKAY WELL YOU
KNOW WE CAN'T GET A DOCTOR OUT
THERE YOU KNOW IN THE FEW HOURS
IT CETERA.
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT --
EXEMPTING FIT TESTING.
MEANS THAT COMMANDER SENSE TIME
PRESSURE BUT ALSO BASICALLY THE
RESPIRATORS KNOXVILLE SERVICE
FUNCTIONS SO IF WITH PEOPLE.
ON COMEY FANATICAL FEEL THE OF
YOU HAVE A MASK AND I GUESS THIS
CASE IT'S FIRE BUT IF YOU ARE AN
INSPECTION CONTROL.
AND BILL USED EQUIPMENT L. AS A
THING IS ACTUALLY SENSUALLY THE
SAME IS NOT USING IT SO I WANT
TO BE CAREFUL THAT IN THE
EXEMPTION.
WE'RE NOT CREATE A SITUATION
THAT.
WORKERS FALSELY THINK THE OTHER
PROTECTION WITH A RESPIRATOR WAY
AND IT REALLY ISN'T BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT IT'S NOT FITTING
WELL IT'S NOT BEING USED
APPROPRIATELY WHATEVER SO CAN
YOU PERHAPS ADDRESS THAT ISSUE --
YES SO THE EMERGENCY REGULAR
REGULATORY LANGUAGE THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED RIGHT NOW DOES
INCLUDE A REQUIREMENT FOR
TRAINING.
AND THE TRAINING DOES INCLUDE AN
APPENDIX THAT GETS INTO THAT
VERY ISSUE SPECIFICS OF THINGS
LIKE -- FACIAL HAIR VERY MUCH
LIMITS THE EFFECTIVENESS OF AN
AND NINETY FIVE THAT IT DOES
NEED TO PROPERLY FIT THE NOSE
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT THAT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS KIND OF FIND A BALANCE
BETWEEN.
NOTHING AND IN IN NINETY FIVE
MASK WITH TRAINING THAT WORKS AS
WELL AS THEY CAN BUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT YOU'RE
RAISING ABOUT.
HOW TO IF IT'S AS WELL AS A CAN
IS ONE THAT WE PLAN TO GET MUCH
MORE IN THE WEEDS OF DURING THE
PERMANENT RULE MAKING PROCESS
THAT -- SHOULD TAKE ABOUT A YEAR
AFTER THE EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS IT SHOULD
BE SOMETIME THIS SUMMER SO IT IS
VERY MUCH A REAL ISSUE AND THE
THE STANDARD THEY'RE MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A MEDICAL
EVALUATION IF IT TESTING IS
THERE FOR VERY GOOD REASON AND
WE WANT. TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
ALMOST ALL CASES THAT STILL
REMAINS AND SO WE DEFINITELY
DON'T WANT TO WE CAN THAT AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
LESS EFFECTIVE THAN THE FEDERAL
STANDARD BUT IT IS AN ISSUE THAT
WE PLAN TO GET MORE INTO DURING
THE PERMANENT.
ROLE MAKING STANDARD BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WHAT I MAKE SURE THAT
WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO SOMETHING
AND THAT THIS ISSUE OF WE CAN'T
GET DOCTORS OUT THERE TO EXAMINE
THIS MANY WORKERS THAT FAST
DOESN'T LEAVE THEM WITH NOTHING
WHICH IS KIND OF WHAT THE
CURRENT REGULATIONS.
TO WELL I I WOULD I WOULD JUST
FOR AND RECOGNIZE ARE STILL
WORKING ON THE ISSUE I I GUESS
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS FIRST OF ALL
WILL BE SURE. TO GIVE PEOPLE
FALSE SENSE OF PROTECTION RIGHTS --
HERE'S A MASK.
BUT THEY'RE NOT WEARING
CORRECTLY SO WHAT AT THE OFFICE
OR OTHER THINGS -- PERHAPS WITH
FIT TESTING TO COULD BE SOME WAY
OF TRAINING CERTAIN.
ALREADY OUT IN THE FIELD AND HOW
TO APPROPRIATELY YOU KNOW HAVING
DONE AND THEN.
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU COULD SO I I
MIGHT JUST BE THE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GONNA HAND
OUT MASKS.
BECAUSE IT'S AN EMERGENCY WHEN A
WAVE THE FIT TESTING BUT THEN
ESSENTIALLY NOW THEY HAVE
AMASSED A SLAP IT ON BUT IT'S
NOT REALLY PERFORMING ITS
FUNCTION.
AND THEN WHAT I AM IS THE WORKER
FALSELY THINKS THE PROTECTED
RIGHT WE WANNA BE SURE TO
ACTUALLY PROTECTED AND SO --
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY. TO TO DO IT
IN A WAY WHERE PERHAPS YOU CAN
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE FIELD TO FREE
THEM PRE TRAINED OR YOU PRE
TRAIN THAT RECOGNIZING YOU KNOW
THAT.
BEFORE YOU SEND THEM OUT TO THE
FIELD IT DOESN'T TAKE THAT LONG
TO TEACH SOMEONE HOW TO FIT
THEIR MASK NOW SO THAT THEY'RE
READY. TO HAVE SOME EDUCATION ON
HOW TO DO IT BECAUSE I JUST
DON'T WANT PEOPLE RECEIVING
MASKS.
THAT DARK NIGHT WEARING
APPROPRIATELY SO I REALIZE
YOU'LL SUPPORT THE BILL HE GONNA
WORK THAT OUT BUT I REALLY THEM
MIGHT BE SURE THAT.
THERE'S SOME WAY PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO GET EDUCATION ABOUT FIT
TESTING -- OTHERWISE THE MASK IS
REALLY NOT THEY'RE GONNA THINK
THEY HAVE PROTECTION AND THAT
I'D ALMOST PREFER THAT THEY'RE
NOT OUT IN THE FIELD AND TELL
HIT THAT TESTING BECAUSE I
OTHERWISE THEY'RE EXPOSED AND
THEY THINK THEY HAVE PROTECTION
THEY DON'T.
THAT IS IN THE APPENDIX A OF THE
PROPOSED REGULATIONS THAT THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THAT SPECIFIC
KIND OF TRAINING.
THE REJECTED YEAH I JUST MIGHT
ADD HAVING GONE TO A FIRE THAT
WAS BURNING FOR FORTY DAYS WERE
ALL WEARING MASKS SOME MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN OTHERS SO I THINK
IT'S PORTANTINO THAT.
PEOPLE NOT HAVE THAT FALSE SENSE
OF SECURITY WHETHER THEY'RE
WORKING IN THE FIELDS ARE JUST.
TRYING TO COPE WITH THE THE THE
SMOKE THE COMES IN I THINK
SACRAMENTO HAD THAT.
OF A FEW MONTHS AGO SO.
I THINK IT'S A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE EDUCATE.
BOTH YOU KNOW THE PUBLIC AS WELL
AS FOLKS YOU KNOW WORKERS WHO DO
SPEND.
WAY TOO MUCH TIME OUT THERE
DURING THIS KIND OF DANGEROUS
WEATHER.
YOU KNOW THE COMMON TO LIKE
CLOUD THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS TO TRY.
TO MAKE FIND THAT BALANCE AND I
ALSO UP WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY
TO CITY COUNCIL THE TWO WORST.
WELL FOR AS WE EVER HAD WERE --
THREE OH SEVEN WERE MY DISTRICT
AND SO WE DID HAVE A LOT OF THIS
IS KIND OF EVEN.
THOUGH THREE ONE IN PEOPLE
THERE'S HARDLY ANYONE THAT WAS
WEARING A MASK -- AND SO IS JUST.
IT WASN'T AS PEOPLE WORKING IT
WAS JUST CITIZENS AND AND AND
PEOPLE IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS SO
THIS IS IMPORTANT I THINK THIS
SEPARATE DIRECTION WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
THAT THAT THAT YOU RAISED A
PARTICULAR DR GRANT.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NOT
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM US SENATOR
FAN OF WHICH WILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR HILL AYE
HILL AYE MORALE.
MORRELL HI JOHN.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL AYE
MITCHELL AYE PAN.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE FIRST [inaudible]
ONE REMEMBER BONTA.
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
TODAY.
WELCOME.
THIS IS WHAT.
WERE UNKNOWN ITEM THIRTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO SEE YOU YOU GUYS HE WAS
WELL GOOD MORNING THE MORNING
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT
CONFORMS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACTS THE F. R. A. TO THE
UNIQUE WORK SCHEDULE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FLIGHT CREW
MEMBERS.
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE IN THE FEDERAL FAMILY AND
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT FMLA.
THE SEER FRA ALLOWS FOR
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE TWELVE WEEKS
OF PAID OR UNPAID JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE AND KEEP THE SAME HEALTH
COVERAGE IF THEY HAVE WORKED.
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
HOURS IN THE PREVIOUS TWELVE
MONTHS UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THEIR WORK FULL
TIME FLIGHT CREW MEMBERSWORK A
SCHEDULE OF THREE TO FOUR DAYS.
AND THIS DOES NOT MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CFRA THIS MEANS
THAT DURING VULNERABLE TIMES
FLIGHT CREWS DO NOT HAVE ALL THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE CFRA MOST
NOTABLY THEY MAY OR MAY NOT KEEP
THEIR EMPLOYER.
IT HEALTH INSURANCE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WOULD MORE PROBABLY
APPROPRIATELY USE THAT FEDERAL
FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE ACT
WORK OUR REQUIREMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FOUR HOURS. FOR
FLIGHT CREW C. F. R. A.
ELIGIBILITY DURING FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE ONE SHOULD NOT BE
WORRYING ABOUT BEING ON ENSURE
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FLIGHT
CREW MEMBERS TO FOCUS ON THEIR
FAMILIES.
I BELIEVE A. B. C. SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT EXTENDS THESE
VALUABLE BENEFITS. TO FLIGHT
CREWS AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS ALREADY DONE UNDER THE FMLA.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION SUPPORT WE DO I
HAVE NOT HAD IT FROM THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA VERY GOOD THANK YOU
WELCOME.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE -- AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY
SOME MOMENTUM MEMBER BOMB BONTA.
PLAYS A CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS
ACT TO THE NONTRADITIONAL WORK
SCHEDULE FLIGHT CREW MEMBERS --
IN THE SAME MANNER THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES UNDER
FMLA AS YOU KNOW CFRA ALLOWS
EMPLOYEES TO TAKE TWELVE WEEKS
OF PAID OR UNPAID JOB PROTECTION --
WHILE RETAINING EMPLOYER
PROVIDED HEALTH -- CARE IF THE
EMPLOYEE HAS WORKED TWELVE
HUNDRED FIFTY HOURS -- IN THE
PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS --
HOWEVER DUE TO OUR UNIQUE -- THE
CHAIR OF OUR WORK -- FLIGHT.
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS I WORK IN A
SINGLE THREE OR FOUR DAY -- TRIP
PER WEEK ARE OFTEN EXCLUDED FROM
CFR A PROTECTIONS UNDER THE
CURRENT TWELVE HUNDRED FIFTY
HOUR.
REQUIREMENT -- BECAUSE OF THIS
EXCLUSION FLIGHT ATTENDANTS ARE
UNABLE TO TAKE SEE IF OUR A
PROTECTED LEVY CARE FOR CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THEIR FAMILY -- IF
THEY BECOME ILL OR INJURED.
ADDITIONALLY CFRA PROVIDES A
UNIQUE LEAVE FOR NEW MOTHERS --
THAT INTERSECTS WITH FMLA TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE -- AND THE RETENTION OF
EMPLOYEE HEALTH -- PROVIDED
BENEFITS -- AT A TIME WHEN
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN NEED TO
RETAIN THOSE HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS MOST -- THIS A
COMMONSENSE THE SOLUTION THAT
BRING CFR A IN LINE WITH THE
FEDERAL FMLA STANDARD -- BY
LOWERING IT THE LOWER IN THOSE
WORK REQUIREMENT HOURS TO FIVE
HUNDRED AND FOUR HOURS FOR THESE
REASONS TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION
OF AMERICA AND THE TV YOU
CALIFORNIA STATE CONFERENCE URGE
AN AYE VOTE ON AB. SEVENTEEN
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT MR WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DâN AGREE TEARS WITH THE
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANE GUSMAN WITH THE TEAMSTERS
AND SUPPORT VERY GOOD ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NO.
ONE PRETTY GOOD WE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR PAN TO PASS -- TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR HILL AYE HILL AYE
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE JACKSON HI JACKSON
HI MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE THOSE FIVE LOADS.
OF OF JUMPING THE GUN SORRY
ABOUT THAT.
FIVE THE THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CARE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- I DID.
SIX AT FIFTY WILL MOVE THROUGH
THE ROLE IF WE COULD WILL START
WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA OF THIS
ITEM SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR JACKSON ALL RIGHT
JACKSON I CONSENT AGENDA HAS
FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT OF MOVING
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SENATOR
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE FOUR TO ONE THE BILL
IS OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. --
TWO SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON HI SENATOR PATH
[inaudible]
HI.
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT IS UP
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
FORTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR JACKSON HI JACKSON I
SENATOR PAN ALL RIGHT CAN I FIVE
VOTES -- THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB THREE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE CALL
YET.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SENATOR JACKSON.
JACKSON I CENTER PAN.
ALL RIGHT.
I FORTY ONE THAT -- THAT BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER. FIVE
A. B. FOUR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL WE HAVE TO MEMBERS MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER TOMORROW.
BROWN'S NO JACKSON HI JACKSON I
PASSED.
HI THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE IT IS
OUT.
OF ITEM NUMBER SIX A BEACH FIVE
TWENTY PLEASE CALL YES A MEMBER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON I SENATOR PAN -- MOVIE
NEVER TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PROBABLY AFTER MEMBER TE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY SENATOR
BREAUX.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI. FOUR VOTES -- THAT
BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER NINE
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE AFTER NUMBER.
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
JACKSON HI. EIGHTY FIVE NINETY
THREE AS FIVE POSTED IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER. ELEVEN A. B. TWELVE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
AFTER MEMBER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO INSURANCE.
COMMITTEE SENATOR JACKSON.
JACKSON AGO AT FIVE VOTE IT IS
OUT ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE AFTER
MEMBER THE MOTION IS DEPRESSED
REVERBERATION SENATOR JACKSON HI
JACKSON HI FIVE VOTES -- THAT
BILL IS OUT I REMEMBER FOURTEEN
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL WE HAVE TO REMEMBER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
PREPARATION SENATOR JACKSON'S.
HI TAX BY FOUR VOTES FOR ONE
THAT IS OUT ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
A. B. EIGHTEEN ZERO FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE AFTER MEMBER THE MOTION
IS TO PSS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR JACKSON.
JACKSON I BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT
IS OUT.
COMPLETED THE WORK OF THE DAYS
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU